[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
science
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
ER Nation games Foundation what is up
guys uh I'm David amadi I'm a video
producer at Gamespot I'm here to stream
Madden NFL 23 and before we start with
all the uh the copycat allegations that
this is just gonna be yet another Madden
let's see for ourselves right uh so we
have the EA play trial it is a 10 hour
trial for those of you who might have
pre-ordered the you know all Madden
Edition which isn't me I cheaped out and
just got an EA play subscription with
Game Pass ultimate so you get 10 hours
so we're gonna hop in here uh show you
guys what's new what isn't new if it's
just the same as Madden 22 you get to
make that decision for yourselves and we
uh you know get to have some fun
so
so yeah actually you know one thing too
if you guys are curious I did recently
make a uh I recently made a video it was
an everything to Know video about Madden
23 it was a little more
um objective just straight facts like
not a lot of my hot takes of how I feel
about Madden because I'm kind of
personally between us I'm in the camp of
it's you know EA's getting a little
lazier maybe with these constant FIFA
and maddens and even 2K uh you know from
2K uh uh NBA 2K they're kind of doing
the same thing too it's just like an
ultimate team cash grab right well for
the last three four years we've been you
know uh the community's been kind of
vocal they've been like hey man Madden
stop doing the uh I don't know just stop
doing the the same BS right like give us
franchise mode give us a very robust
franchise mode stop making Ultimate Team
pay to win things like that I hear you
I'm with you but uh you know I got this
10 hour trial so okay let's just see
what we got right
uh all right so I'm just gonna hop into
a couple of uh maybe like some
head-to-head exhibition matches if you
guys want to see you know face the
franchise I don't know why you would but
if you want to see it I'll pop in there
um you know we'll we'll mess around
maybe I'll go into the Forbidden
Ultimate Team
but for now you're stuck with me for
about an hour and a half of straight
Football let's go let's get in it
I see sugars in the chat hello sugar
she's a friend of mine she's also a
Broncos fan so actually she's no longer
a friend of mine I've renounced her in
fact why don't we do yeah okay sugar why
don't we do a Raiders vs Broncos just to
start it off right you got Russ I got
Devonte Adams it's a new year new me new
us let's do it
um so just as a heads up guys too so
there is one new game mechanic it's
called Precision or it's like skill
based passing and with skill based
passing there are two ways that you can
operate with the gameplay one is
controlling the power one is controlling
the accuracy and the the mode that I
chose was the accuracy one and I played
a test game before I logged on here and
I threw a pick six right away so
here we go
let's see what we got
we got a pretty Lively chat going man I
know I know not everyone here is going
to be a Madden fan that's totally fine
you know what I mean like like I said
I'm with you guys too I want
I want Madden and I want these EA Sports
Games to come back in again to actually
be decent and good and strong and not
just a roster update you know what I
mean like straight up so
[Music]
but yeah man so that's just
that's just where I'm at
oh no dude we can't have Broncos fans in
here come on gotta get some Raider fans
in here
Matt snake it must be though that your
boss assigned your playlist on stream
you have to pretend that it's fun
actually no I'm the one who offered I'm
the one who offered the stream uh it's a
good way to spend my afternoon I get to
have fun I get to play games instead of
you know work at my desk right like come
on who doesn't want that
um
I shouldn't have said that
let's pop in
have you seen the Saints black helmet in
game yet I I don't know man and also
chat this is a uh let me know about the
volume by the way guys it's like loud I
gotta lower it it's a little loud in my
ears actually but it's coming up next
um yeah guys apologies in advance I know
there might be a little bit of a delay
in the chat uh but I will try to talk to
all you guys I love talking to Chad I
love engaging with y'all and I'm
probably gonna lose anyway so you know
who cares
Stadium while I'm here well I got you
guys let's go through a Nostalgia trip
it's like my favorite thing to do on the
streams they're only stream opt-in and
so when I do I love to go through the
Solita trips and um how many of you guys
know how or how many guys have played
NFL streams
and for those of you who haven't played
NFL streams just play Madden let me know
what your favorite Madden was back today
was it like oh seven was it you know
touchdowns are you a little bit younger
and you're more on like that 14 or even
OG when they take them with like Madden
let me know keep laughing my own heart
all right
either yeah presentation looks okay uh
eyes are a little buggy though they can
never get the crowds right you know what
I mean
oh
we got who that is that is that a
Bengals term or is that a Saints term
it's like one of them it's like who dad
or who day you never tell
yeah
hope things that Graphics look exact
like the last few years it's pretty hard
to tell the difference you know what I
mean uh it is what it is oh my God
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Applause]
shut up 86
. oh my God that was amazing
[Applause]
they'll begin on the ground with Jacobs
and he's going to take this ahead for
right around three yards but no more
than that second down
now Carr on the Bublé
[Applause]
[Music]
so I think that was the I think that was
the uh
I tried to lead the receiver and he
threw it behind defensively for the
Derek Carr jokes
we know that that's pretty obvious the
beauty though is is happening early if
they don't pay cancel the game and go
play the whole team I'll give them a sec
[Music]
[Applause]
Gregory day's first
you can be the F meter bro just just
every time I throw a pick every time I
fumble
and keep like trash
[Applause]
and make a difference
some mixed feelings on the uh
the graphics some people think it's like
the same as last year some plenty it
might be better you guys should put some
context if you think the graphic is
better let me know
and if you don't think it's that much
better you probably
[Applause]
[Applause]
news
and I think that discouraged him from
taking off and made him try to pass down
Devonte Williams
[Music]
third down Wilson
There we go
get me in there
Chandler Jones one of the best
at Chester New York in for the sack
fourth down Wilson trots off and on
comes Brandon McManus for the Denver
field goal
McManus is good and that will extend
their lead even foreign
and also most of the game engine when
Unreal Engine I think five that we're on
right Unreal Engine 5 starts to be
widely used
all you guys holy [ __ ] I'm like not used
to
I'm not used to the uh oh God we're
loading up the box too
on the ground is Jacobs to start the
drive and nothing much materializing
there on the first down they still have
the uh that's it they still have that
like the game day momentum thing
so okay how the hell do I need one car
there we go that's what I'm talking
about
there we go has anything changed in this
game Randy B these games come out each
year and barely changing yes and no
depending on
your your uh opinion of uh
so what has changed is something called
field sense which is like I don't know
Hassan on Twitch mentioned it pretty
well you said like let's see these
animations it's all about like these
like new animations on tackling hitting
everything mid-air blocks a bunch of
stuff whether or not it's actually get
off me whether or not it's actually
effective
um
and that is not gonna get it done
already down two scores they're gonna go
for this rather than settle for three
thank you
so this is a horrible
they'll go for it it's Carr
oh that's it um
[Applause]
margin you haven't played a Madden game
in years well welcome what was your last
napkin how long ago ready to start their
next Drive
going now Wilson on first down
[Music]
oh my God it's across Midfield and
inside the 45. we're here Joe uh we're
here for like an hour and a half so
there'll be plenty of time don't don't
even worry about it
plenty of time
now a first down carry it's Williams the
thing is that most uh people don't
actually like that at least a lot of the
the Madden haters kind of get in our
audience sometimes not what they want
they want franchise
but do not worry stick around worry Joe
I will go into uh Ultimate Team after
this they are looking at a second and
five situation who else would you how
does the game feeling so far compared to
last year it feels the same the only
thing that's really messing me up is the
Precision passing apparently the like
YouTube Madden Community said they uh
they liked it after 41-yard line they
got used to it but it took a long time
it's it's hard man
I might swap to the power position
[Applause]
system that'd be amazing are you kidding
me second and ten to throw as Wilson how
quickly to Judy and he's gonna have
another first down as the tackle comes
at the Raiders 17 hard line
what was your favorite number James
throwing catch right there and so far in
this game the alleys have been
oh Adam the bomb says looks nice and
they're taking advantage of it
from the red zone now they'll look to
throw
right back to Judy and it's complete um
[Music]
you got the mad at 23 video game PS4 for
Early Access right down the field and
just like that they're gonna be set up
with a first and goal
foreign
[Applause]
yes it is live that's what we're doing
right now
that is perfect so now McManus uh Chris
Houston is this my first time playing
group I had Early Access this is Early
Access and also my first time playing uh
Madden 23 not my first time playing
Madden ever but looking at the score you
might as well I wouldn't uh faulty I
think this is my first time playing
um but yeah man this is uh this is do
you get it by either pre-ordering all
Madden Edition which costs 100 bucks I
don't know if you guys necessarily want
that you know what I mean
um they had no alley to be the other
ways to have which you can get if you
have Xbox game pass ultimate I think we
don't want to call this desperation time
comes out in like three days
Hassan the all Madden Edition is a
hundred bucks dude but the standard
edition is 60 and if you play on next
strand PS5 series X it's seven
I think you did but let's face it you
mentioned this to me on a break earlier
in the game yeah energy level hasn't
been there it supports this competition
to push them I
agreement
oh God they got the kill streak on my
screen is shaking
this play action now car
and open is Keelan Cole complete
yeah he'll be corralled well up field
right around the 40-yard line on first
down Drake and he's going to take this
ahead for right around three years on
the cover not since the 16-bit days
correct correct they they did a
throwback uh
[Applause]
of all time
hey do I have a match cover on or off
what do you mean by that match cover
like the auto flip on defense 40 yards
on the catch and run and Roy CD it's one
thing to watch a great run but when it's
a great run with broken contact it's
like a cherry on top that was a nice
game eight bucks and 90 bucks in Canada
[Music]
[Applause]
touchdown remember
all right come on I gotta do this for
Raider Nation gotta get a little door
again but they're gonna be set up in
great shape but first get in there oh my
God he is gonna lose yardage here
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's it oh are you kidding me it's
opened up and then it just disappeared
two minutes remaining in this first half
more play
I don't feel good about this coverage
oh no there it is
[Applause]
Daniel Carlson that was a bad kick okay
well whatever and it's 17-7 uh so
something you can chat or might hear me
repeat myself a couple times totally
fine
um because I know we're getting new
folks in the Stream a lot and it's
always good to kind of repeat
occasionally uh just to share the
details about this game and so to answer
uh Kirsten's question you know they
asked are there any notable new features
the two off the top of my head is fuel
sense which is kind of like subtle
always working in the background you're
not going to notice it
um right off the bat it's just something
it's like you know all animations it's
the way that your player runs Cuts
scrambles hits you know it's just
they're supposed to be like the first
exercise near the end of the
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm not used to
that's it there we go
radar Nation we are back let's go sugar
I hope you're watching Brandon this is
to get wrecked rumples he should know
better than to make a throw like this
is definitely not his best ball he
should know better
Broncos Nation Let's Ride
and Russell
uh
uh that's what I want to throw too I
kind of want to just Chuck a bomb to
pull but now after the INT in the car
that's this is incomplete
it's second down now
no no that's still a thing that's the
thing they just added that the other
elements in it so you can still do high
low passes but combined with the other
stuff so watch I'm gonna I'm gonna throw
this past I'm a lobbit to Coal no I'm
not I'm gonna I'm gonna try to hit
waller or Adams on the cut and you'll
see this like reticle as well as like a
meter okay
okay you see that so there was like this
blue there was like a blue green green
being good I think blue being perfect
um and so I was trying to pick it up
I think green is bullet who is touch and
then the orange I still don't know how
it [ __ ] works completely honest but
it is different and the one thing that
is easier to control is the the little
like kind of Mark that side Mark that
you can kind of uh
shift the trajectory of the ball it used
to be they could still like lead your
receivers but um you can do it like more
precise with this method supposedly we
our reviewer Mark Delaney um he's
actually making an article breaking the
Precision passing down specifically and
um
and it's uh you know it's pretty cool
let's talk about it as well excellent
job staying disappointed coverage and
making that stop I promise like I said
man I I have my old Madame instincts
yeah so like when I saw the X Factor
light out for Devante on that last play
and he made that cut I just held the
bullet down and led to the left but
really what I should have done was do
like a high touch pass or something Out
Of Reach of the defender or some [ __ ] so
it's like I just gotta get my my head in
the game y'all
[Applause]
right sideline but not in the field they
say it's incomplete
little too far it brings up third down
both
usually whichever ones end up going on
sale halfway through the year that's
what I did for Madden 22. I think hole
car gonna throw oh that's it that's
complete and that's gonna be knocked
away
[Music]
smart enough to avoid the toes
told them you might want to stop coming
after me to Outfield because I just
broke up another pass and took away a
big shot
hangs out to the right it's no good and
they will not cut into that 10-point
lead boy that's three points you really
expect to have
Constitution to me because an NFL kicker
should make this kick in his sleep the
Broncos onto the field ready
I love these Throwbacks in the comments
oh why would I swap that I'm just trying
to die for it
dude that throw did look good didn't it
I think the 100 cakes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now the Broncos Nate Allen so it's an
early access for Standard Version if you
have E8 play because you got a discount
for having sex
it is early access if you have EA play
whether or not you have the standard
edition or not
um the well sorry the Early Access trial
which is a 10-hour trial
which is what this is so everything
you're seeing here is basically what you
would have access to have EA play I
haven't even bought the game yet and I'm
playing right now with the Early Access
Oh I thought I set them
[Music]
they counted
[Music]
them yeah I gotta say man Madden 23 is
Russian music
or actually accurate because they always
hate the Raiders
no doubt about it I heard you get really
upset correct yeah that's what this is
we're doing EA player right now
so that's a pick six that's a big six
get out of me oh God damn it God I feel
like my guys are so slow
[Applause]
following that turnover as he'll try to
get some points here before halftime
yeah
the crossover
did I change my time zone on my console
no dude I don't know specific you know
West Coast so you are good all right
Adam's room for a Cole who is on play
action oh my God I'm almost
[Applause]
done
let's go oh that was nasty
that's my QB on the run under pressure
Big Shot downfield Raider Nation let me
hear you in the chat
line for you guys always have these good
plays and then I choke on the goal line
man I swear so the big play means just
like that they'll operate from the red
zone now on first down welcome back
sugar you missed me uh destroying the
[ __ ] out of Russell's car with a play
fake to Jacobs
[ __ ] the rifles one that's intercepted
picked off by Justin Edmonds are going
to take possession here
oh Lord the Broncos onto the field ready
to start
lead maybe they're just looking to give
him to the locker room
[Applause]
to start the drive but that was
incomplete it certainly didn't appear
what
did you guys see that
I followed the ball
what the hell was that
[Laughter]
are you [ __ ] me hey yo field sense
guys look at that
hahaha
[Laughter]
uh
[Laughter]
all right I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
oh initially so you tried to get
something out I shouldn't be laughing I
should be I should be uh successfully
I should be excited right
Let's Ride
oh chat I love you guys no way no way
and Mark him down way up close to the
40th to 39. what the [ __ ] that good for
22. all right I'm gonna turn on the AC
I'm here right now we're the visiting
Broncos taking the lead to the locker
room as we send you to Orlando to check
in with Jonathan Coachman at Rea Sports
halftime report coach all right Brandon
thanks very much welcome everyone to our
brand new studios here in downtown
Orlando in the EA Sports halftime
reports first order in business though
let's get a look at the next gen stats
in that first half from Denver and even
though they've got the big cushions I
would imagine they'd like to see a
little more out of their passing game
pretty pedestrian numbers through two
quarters of play both teams making their
final adjustments seven awareness and
for the call the second half let's send
you back out to Allegiant Stadium all
right and Brandon God
what are they burning me in they're
[Music]
here let me
my runs are [ __ ]
the throws are fine
all right coach thank you welcome
everyone back number three
[Applause]
anyone here actually been to uh
Allegiant stadium before whether to see
the Raiders or to see like you know
whoever
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[ __ ] me
God I lit him up dude
[Music]
but that game was gave me a heart attack
the game gave me like realize I bet like
500 bucks on the money line and that
last order in the overtime
for the game he writes our message
training camp not the ball free take it
away from the other team and now you
have that chance that his stick felt
good they really liked it at you they
try and fool but it's hard I'm trying to
like but you're right about it
coming up here looking for three yards
to pick up the first oh my God
[Music]
Wilson now to throw on third down oh
nice
work
honestly I'm not even that sure I just
think that it's like the animations so
it's like a passive thing that's always
happening you know what I mean
every time you make a cut every time you
uh you know pressure the QB you're
blocking just blow line and stuff it's
all
all passive stuff that's happening in
the background
and not what he was supposed to add like
realism for the Judgment so here comes
it's not like a like a feature
you know they're defensive the punt to
start things out and now Charles to the
offense get in here
okay the first half was theirs but now
let's get the momentum back on our side
we force the punt now let's go down
field and score if we do the ball away
for the second half
[Applause]
I was like
I do like this coverage though
I do like this coverage I wanna I wanna
just Chuck a missile to devonto now it's
car
okay
that's the frustration is definitely
setting in because they've thrown it to
him over and over unable to come up with
a catch thus far I think he knew he
would have his challenges against his
secondary I don't think he saw a goose
egg at this point in the game
our deep door there on second down
Battle Royale
credit the secondary credit the
defensive game plan they've been in his
head pocket all game long they
understood coming in that he was a big
time receiver
throwing his car on third down
he's got a nice
and he's going to get this one deep in
my playing Commander 23. yes yes
the Early Access
anyone who has the a plagues and
uh-hour trial or whatever just
leadership
to make a big yeah it does come out on
the 19th um but if you're in all Madden
please drop something
owner or if you have V8 you get to play
as parties uh today four yards on the
pickup there and it'll be second down
sometimes with the running game you've
just gotta stick with it
so a strong drive here to lead off this
Thursday
[Applause]
but we certainly mean business now maybe
a better term improvement Drive they
proved it to themselves that they were
ready to go
to see it on the uh next to the Denver
score
[Applause]
following the touchdown ready to kick it
away is Carlson
and he'll just sit on this one as their
Drive will start at the 25 and Denver
getting set to take the field pretty
important third quarter drive for it and
momentum has sort of shift in the other
direction after that last touchdown as
they nurse this small lead
they run on first down gets him a couple
up to the 27. they'd love to just strike
back with a touchdown oh man
Derek Mouse on Twitch this pretty much
looks just like last year's games
specifically field sense
[Applause]
which is like the animations I guess
a million new animations
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you can barely hear me over the game
volume not a problem let me just lower
that baby right there thank you for
letting me know
um
[Applause]
let me see
[Applause]
him
all right sorry I had to check something
real quick on the side but let me just
chat back
do the devs come out saying this is
gonna blow people away or something like
that Derek you're talking about what you
call PR speech uh that's you know I mean
what are they supposed to say right are
they going to be like nah this is craft
do the same support of course they're
always going to be like hey we use you
know busted our asses making this many
animations or hey we've you know been
really trying to add these features to
franchise mode or we're looking at the
like run meta or we're trying to add
season passes and things like that's the
ultimate team so and now a chance to I
mean No One's Gonna you know no one at
EA is gonna be like hey this is just the
same game pay US 60 bucks
at their own 20-yard line
he'll give it to Jacobs to start the
drive oh that was so nice
I keep thinking I can Juke with uh with
Jacobs but I gotta truck people that's
what he is
by Christian McCaffrey's
or whatever
really nice
run past uh why why are you teaching me
about rpos I know what the [ __ ] RPO
is oh my God
from up near the 40 now after the big
play to start here also I'm not playing
with that princess Aaron Rodgers yeah
call him out call him out they go with
Jacobs again nowhere to go you see uh
Aaron Rodgers on the uh on the bar stool
like podcast or whatever and big cat
like to his face to ask them how many
grandmas he's killed you're not getting
vaccinated that was well they trust him
first and foreign
as well oh respect respect I wow that's
actually a lot of respect because you uh
you know I would have you guys love you
guys are so intense about the the
Packers you know what I mean so and
Rogers was good to your guys's team to
be honest so respect for you uh
here's Wilson
[Applause]
[Applause]
looked like a sure win for the defense
flushed towards right
and past the third round
the rushing numbers for Wilson maybe
down from earlier in his career but he's
still a threat to go showing it they're
picking up the first down now it's
Wilson
he'll get this to hamler over the middle
and he'll be brought down it should be
burning some timeouts huh
got him running like he's young again
hey that year was an insane year for uh
for rpos for QBs that ran dude who uh he
said forget about the lip sync that one
drops on the kick by McManus is good and
they scratched the lead to six it's 20
to 14 now so they get to three but you
wonder now is that going to be enough
excellent question because when I look
at the smiles on that side of the field
it's a little tight aren't they if they
had scored a touchdown there
all right we're back
um
um yeah it looks like looks like stream
might be buffering uh here and there I
definitely have my
I know my my feed to the gaming spot
server should be good uh you know OBS
didn't say that it was like you know off
or anything like that so it might it's
probably it might be my uh uh uh my
internet maybe
um or you know it's just YouTube uh
acting a fool so
[Music]
[Applause]
we're about to score this dub
uh
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
how scary
two minute drive hopefully we can get
the dub yeah man I I uh two minutes you
know a former Game Spot
um
producer that we have her name was
Persia she was like a new streamer and
she was so much fun yeah
man and 20 are Madden 19 and we have
just the most insane game ever it was
like down to the final wire off like a
kickoff return like on 30 to like 40 or
something it was disgusting oh that okay
that was Precision passes
that was the Precision or skill based
passing
um mechanic whatever you just saw right
there you saw the Bulls marker that
Bullseye marker you saw the I mean I
threw a high touch pass there's that
meter and everything and Devonte did
look at different animation to reach it
so that distinctly feels new uh to me
now Carr
oh that was a bad pass
I just got so excited
oh that's certainly not the worst thing
it stops the clock and lets your offense
catch its breath and lets us that tail a
little bit now I expect them to call a
couple plays in a Hummel so they're
ready if a tackle happens in bounds
car
and that falls to the ground incomplete
tomorrow
this offense was on the Move now two
straight in computer how's that passing
yeah man hit or miss that that Devonte
pass was
clean but these other passes I'm making
are kind of ass so we'll just
throwing his car
he's open that's complete to his tight
end Waller
[Music]
he's just first down as they're able to
get the third down conversion
[Applause]
Jacob's gonna try the middle
and he'll get this one down to about the
17. the Raiders going to use one of
their timeouts as they'll stop it with
just over 40 seconds to go in the game I
know they got a little yardage there but
I'm not sure
that's uh that's enough to run a uh
PA Pro right
always viewed the PA Pro as like a
cheap play because it like never goes
wrong
this is close enough iPhone slot
the last run gotta come this Play Almost
Never Fails
here's car
he can't get a throw away he's taken
down
now another timeout called four by the
offense as the clock will stop with 37
seconds to play
what the [ __ ] was that
oh Lord all right
give me I'm gonna dude that play has to
oh here we go
now car the Raiders Delta third and long
after that second
car to throw Waller
[Music]
when this drive is over
okay maybe Adam's on on the law maybe
don't throw out now Carr gotta have this
one
and it's gonna be batted down
[Music]
um
[ __ ] you Russell
the win for the Broncos seemingly
assured they go down Lenny now the
Raiders going to burn their third and
final timeout as they get into 26
seconds to go in the foot if I made that
a high pass Devonte would have gone that
was my it was 100 my fault Band of
Brothers attitude right just us against
the wall and get it done
[Applause]
fans get out of my stream
Raider fans I will redeem you
uh before five o'clock
uh
[Applause]
considering that
um the first play was literally the
Broncos scoring on my uh return entire
game but when you throw one in the pool
I'll take it I'll take it everyone that
you're getting stronger hey sometimes
you win sometimes you lose
uh someone wants Niners and Eagles I
promised another person in chat that I
would go into uh Ultimate Team at some
point
if he's still here I definitely want to
pop in there open up a pack that I got
see what we get
um
but
manners Eagles could be fun
Derek what am I playing on I am playing
on uh Xbox series X right now that's
what I'm playing on and that's probably
what I will play on when I eventually
get the code can I uh turn the regular
passing back yes yes you can I think
God where is it It's gotta be game
options maybe right
a skill level Pro but unfortunately
going to uh so passing time here we go
so this is the the new thing
um you have passing slowdown which you
can put on only on offline pit um play
what it does is it slows the game down
so you could like make your actual throw
precise in like slow motion rather than
at game speed I kept that off because I
think that's gonna develop bad habits
especially if you try to um you know
play online
um yeah you have the freeform medical
max distance speed of the reticle
whether it's visible or not what if the
meter is visible or not and the two
skill based passing types there's two of
them one is centered around
accuracy and one is centered around
power
um
placement and accuracy placement that's
the power one I think uh yeah yeah
placement enables control over the
placement of the pass and finer control
over the past strength whereas the
accuracy it's kind of like an extra
element so it's the placement of the
pass but then finer control over uh the
accuracy of the pass itself and the
classic it just disables it and it
brings it back to the OG type of passing
so that's what we got there
uh is there anything special they did
for Madden with his passing
um you know R.I.P to the goat John
Madden yeah I well it's you know
what you're saying the thing that they
did is you know they put them on the
cover
um they did a legacy Madden game when
you boot up this a game for the first
time you go into an NFC versus AFC match
and it's called the John Madden uh
Legacy game it's like a game that they
do in his honor so that's kind of the
opening for it
um I don't know if I could replay it
again because I think it's just when you
start the game for the first time
um as for what elements they add from
him elsewhere I'm not too sure what I do
know
is that in Ultimate Team they have
seasons it's like it's like a season
pass or a battle pass for those of you
familiar with battle passes and like
fortnite war zone Destiny Apex you know
every live service game is now having a
battle pass right so Madden is no
different they've got these things
called field passes and there's one for
the season there's one I think for like
Ultimate Team specific and there's a
general one that you can get progress in
for playing like literally anything I
think if you play franchise if you play
exhibition you still get progress
towards one of them for those of you
familiar with MLB the Show
um it's very similar to what MLB the
Show does so kind of a good change in my
mind
um
GG sugar thank you for joining in and
bringing all that energy uh you know I
know chat loves having your presence
here I appreciate you popping in and uh
log on Destiny tonight so we can play
bye
um Nate says how do you get the game
Trials EA play or or pre-ordering the
Madden Edition which is like 100 bucks
so real quick though before I start
talking more uh to chat because I could
talk forever uh someone said Niners
Eagles I think I'm kind of interested in
getting that going someone said Packers
we could do we could do a quarter like
you know just a quarter of each
um Team or different teams so you can
see what they're like I have no problem
with that so and that way it'll be a
little faster you know I just had to do
a full game for the Raiders
unfortunately loss but
let's do uh someone said Niners uh
Eagles I'll do that first uh real quick
I'll do a quarter of that
um but you get to decide if I play as
the Niners or the Eagles
and I will
pass Philly
oh yeah
there they are
yeah George Kittle Nick both of Fred
Warner you got Lane Johnson Darius Slay
and Jason Kelsey Ellen plays the Niners
now I need to versus anybody
my boss is a huge dinos fans actually a
lot a lot of folks at uh Gamespot are
huge Niner fans
um
you know they just they love it I mean
we're also based in San Francisco so
kind of kind of makes sense although I'm
a little sad they moved uh away it would
have been nice to have both the warriors
uh and
it would have been nice if they had both
the Warriors and the uh um
what should we call it and the and the
Niners in SF that would have been tight
straight Lance a throw a deep guy he's
not right
it looks like I throw it short dude
and run outside we got Elijah Mitchell
he was injured last year right I
remember
someone getting him like I ended up
picking around outside anyway more of a
mid okay good to know
taste is the man has arm strength more
than Jimmy okay let me hear Let me let
me let me pick throw it throw it mid
then as the as the Niners
let's get get Trey working that arm a
little bit
uh
uh Bulls there they are
all right let's do it
um
I'll do throw a medium I think that's
fair I think that's fair
uh you know what no [ __ ] it we'll go
throw it deep well let's let's throw the
bombs I'm just gonna Chuck I mean it's
only a quarter anyway right uh I want to
defend against Jalen hurts
running I think
on a container no I'll defend the uh
in the medium pass that's fine
let them earn it
all Jimmy does is win yeah kinda
even teams no sir
uh uh quarter Lanes yeah okay six
minutes is fine for one quarter
um
play clock remaining Eagles time weather
yeah that's all fine let's do it
now just for a second it's the NFL on EA
Sports hey look at Trey yo are you ready
for some football
next on Madden football
sailing hurts
I'm miles Sanders
the ones I've ever had an eagles player
one of my fantasy team I think was uh we
shading it is
we get you ready for some football in
in Jimmy
[Applause]
all right so for those of you around for
the Raider game I am not going to
lateral on the five yard line as soon as
I uh
returning from his end zone is Ray ring
the clowns
[Applause]
49ers offense let's throw a bomb on
Thursday yeah
[Applause]
right out of the gates Lance going to
the air
and his first pass here is gonna this
was good accuracy at least I'm not like
just this is going to be woefully off uh
it won't be the last time both of them
believe they are the superior this play
is usually good at the wheel route
usually freeze McLeod up and my to throw
on second and two Lance he'll fire this
deep for ayuke and that will be
incomplete
have some power to it
replacing the rub no three and out there
throwing now is Lance there you go
man open that's Debo Samuel and he is
they're able to
division
read options
receivers do the pass tree I'm bad at
reading though
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
negative plays
classic forwarded let's do a deep post
to iuc
[Applause]
the Lance gonna throw
that although that looked really bunk
but he taught that so down to the Eagles
but we used to see him the guy that you
can say the number one receiver yeah
okay yeah yeah that did look weird that
wasn't just that wasn't just me the way
the ball flew out of his hand that's how
you increase your Madden rating really
sucks no doubt about that you know and
you know something I people hear about
that right soon so from Philadelphia
territory now here's a First and Ten
it's fine as long as you win right all
the bugs and the glitches
[Applause]
Texas
[Applause]
and escape this drive
[Applause]
now Lance
[Music]
um
now before they run this fourth down
play we might have got took some
accident they'll have two remaining as
we step aside here in this first quarter
so on fourth down here's the Australia
native
to punt this one away Mitch will shoot
[Applause]
and that'll hit in the end zone much too
much leg there that'll be a Touchback
for the first time we get to see this
Philadelphia offense let out by their
dual threat quarterback now in his third
season Jalen hurts Dan Bose has got five
r's
he's got five bars and of course I put
him in coverage
anywhere impression he goes down
[Applause]
played for their team's First Take of
the game
right out of the gate in this defense
hoping that that's a harbinger of things
to come yeah when you give up a first
place sack makes your quarterback
[Applause]
Queen interceptions
Jimmy Duncan looks no different than 22.
yeah you know from a visuals point of
view probably not going to look that
much different
um we had some folks in chat say that it
looked better to their eyes some folks
said it didn't your mileage will vary uh
but it it's more of the feel I think
it's more of the gameplay feel
um there actually is a performance or a
Fidelity mode I put on performance mode
for the higher frame rate I could always
swap to Fidelity mode but depending on
the uh stream like bandwidth is not
going to become a different subtle thing
so I just thought you guys would much
rather see
you know what I mean
throwing again on second down Lance
there you go hey if you're watching that
was for you
trying to study
let's take the early turnover and
convert blue Maguire means stop lying
about what this is
what am I lying
anytime a defense has to defend a short
field you usually end up seeing the
result we saw giving up points gold with
the extra point and that makes the score
seven nothing
laughs
you've got to uh
tweeting on uh or not tweeting but
messaging on Twitch
so I've got the pressure of having my uh
having my boss watch me play watch me
play Madden I can't I can't slowly the
the Niners good name out of the field
here come the Eagles
NFC team things a lot different than the
last time they were on the field
remember they threw the interstate I
disappointed the uh the Creator fan base
but then again you know
a response
although hoping this here will be a
little different they start on the
ground here at Sanders oh oh what a Juke
into space
miles Sanders
75 yards and the Eagles are able to
strike uh
hey if you're watching can you turn off
the stream real quick
I think you can get any more efficient
or tidy
One play 75 yards End Zone yeah
efficient tidy
[Applause]
that means
oh boy
was drawn up on the Whiteboard Big Time
play Big Time results
something something something at least
we're having fun right that's that's the
here's the clown from his end zone
winning's not everything right
it's all about as long as we're having
fun Jonathan Perry the passing seems
better it is it is if you can do it
right I keep I keep messing up capacity
because I'm not used to it but like
there's a few there's a few dimes that I
threw that was really really good what
happened the last time I just have to
like cognizantly think ahead of time
like all right I want a low I want to
hide pretty simple here again
and we'll make it a high pass if you're
a good football team you're being
covered you spend that time on the
sideline you study what's on the notes
in the tablets oh
[Applause]
he'll take this all the way down inside
it felt good on it felt good saying it
out loud really
good saying it out loud
oh boy
there is no defeat only surrender and
surrenders for the week that whole thing
was
time uh we've ever
it was the mercy rule was 35 and up so
if you were winning by 35 points then it
was an automatic Mercy we had to uh
yeah
[Applause]
I'm never gonna throw a jump ball again
it's a ray ray
Tennessee
I'm never doing that again for sure
is the Deep Crossing route still uh
money kind of yeah if it's the one that
I'm thinking of I think so in his first
three years I threw a couple of uh play
action crosses that didn't work out but
84 yards rushing forward you got some
Eagle fans saying finish this game I
don't know man I don't know
I did say a quarter each
well tell you what oh yes
[Applause]
we'll we'll let them finish this drive
if they because it's only second now if
they score then that'll be an l and if
we uh as they've got it they don't score
consider it a half it's like a half
blowing is hurts the field goals don't
count
right side
a great move in there
it's okay to do what you want bro I
appreciate that you know man I'm
I'm just trying to I'm trying to please
everyone you know what I mean I want I
want everyone watching to have something
they can look forward to
um
we're probably gonna score this field
goal it's very hard to block skills
you see what happened it's hard to get
the ball in there not enough space there
yeah okay GG so that was the first
quarter let's uh let's do another uh
Team dynamic
and we'll get some other teams whatever
you uh uh playing am I versus real
people are Bots it's AI it's offline
mode I'm not I'm not playing anyone
online yet I think I can uh and for
those of you who get the trial I think
you can but nah otherwise I'm just uh
you know doing it normal let's do some
random team wow I pressed random and
went to the Raiders that's divine
intervention
um
who do we want to see huh you want to
see the bro nah not the Browns not the
Browns uh do you want to see Rams you
want to see the Vikes
from Vikings check out some of the new
uniforms alternate uni so I can do that
whoever whatever team we get I'll put on
some alternate units Colts and bills
okay
I can I can mess with that see Matt Ryan
with this new team they got
my uh the best player on my fantasy team
last year Jonathan Taylor we'll do the
Colts and let's do uh the bills I'm
gonna play as the bills though because I
love Josh Allen
I love Josh Allen so much everyone said
that he was gonna be a bust when the
bills got him early especially over
other QBs and he is like
just a legend I love him
and honestly it gives me an excuse to
root for a like Canon bazooka type QB
that is in my homes you know what I mean
so
uh yeah let's check out these let's
check out these UNIS
uh edit uniforms what do we got
we got the current home we got the
current away yeah the classics we got a
color Rush oh that's nice
we got the color Rush alternates
alternate Classics oh that's nice for
those stripes
the Red Bull
and we're back to the currents
I think you can mix and match too right
you can like
yeah you could you could you can mess
with it and give them like the color
Rush Jersey and like the away pants or
the alternates
see what we got Josh Allen mid someone's
a Patriots fan
someone someone's in the AFC East and
doesn't like uh are they the north ABC
North right
now it's AFC East for sure they gotta be
do they have the red helmets they might
here let me
um
let me go back to the classics and
adjust it do they have the red helmets
let's see
ooh the 2000s this one
of the 1990s lighter shade
yeah that's that's a I like that
I like that one a lot
kind of like the
red the all red is is nice we do red and
white
oh you're the Broncos fan boss right on
you must have been loving the stream uh
in the beginning well I like those black
shoes
I really like that
if they had black pants
that would have been
legit
I don't know if they have black though
it's it's got to be just just blue
I'll take the Navy
hey let's go with that
I like uh
I'm going with that
did it save
yeah I did okay good
let's check out the Colts
um uniforms see what they got
so they got their classics
got their alternate
I like the alternates for them I don't
like the all-white but the color Rush
yeah called Navy
alternative all white turned away option
2019
let me see some grow bags man
whoa
damn
this is a Peyton Manning era now
he didn't go he didn't go to the Broncos
yet until uh
until I want to say 2011. or 20 it might
have been 2011.
that that hit that hits
[ __ ]
what do you guys think if you have any
Colts fans in here you should let me
know uh
let me know what you like I'm gonna mess
with the helmets but then let me know
which of the the sets you prefer
if you want to go to like the 1950s
throwback the 95 throwback whatever it
might be
oh we got a lot of football fans I love
that you got a Falcons fans got Steelers
got they got some football football fans
with West Ham there there you go
okay a couple of couple of nice helmets
I think I'm gonna I think I'm gonna go
I think I might go 95 man oh that's
that's nice I'm gonna go
live all this for one quarter
dead ass man yeah you're right
let me
I'ma hurry it up my bad I just I got so
consumed by this customization
all right so we got the 95 Colts and
then we got I'll throw it deep are you
kidding me
come on
uh yeah we're gonna defend Jonathan
Taylor absolutely
outside right
let's do it all this room recording that
was good that was really good
you got a Fiverr to see me play with the
Detroit Lions No Cap hey man after uh
seeing Aiden Hutchinson drop Billie Jean
uh on Hard Knocks man
EA Sports and if it's in the game dude I
I've had Billie Jean stuck in my head
ever since that video dropped on Twitter
of uh abeyton Hutchinson
like throwing it down dude he he ate
that [ __ ] he snapped I swear
got Keith Howard saying where the cheese
heads at we got someone from Wisconsin
here earlier
yeah
for the first time we take a look at
Matt Ryan Alex how do you play Early you
have EA play Too download it man uh
download the game if you have Xbox on EA
play or whatever I think uh go check and
you'll be able to install it and then
when you log in it'll be like hey this
is only a trial for like 10 hours
[Applause]
that's what I would do
one quarterback in season one of the
most decorated quarterbacks Ravens fans
that's the thing that's the thing I love
about if there's anything that I enjoy
about Madden it's not really about the
game itself it's the people like just
football in general because when Madden
comes out the music season is around the
corner and the season is around the
corner that means there's football and
that is just a good thing it also means
that it's fall which is my favorite
season uh fall in holidays are coming up
you know like length is going to be
December you got Christmas games you got
playoffs it is just an electric time the
second half of the year is my favorite
passing situation
good job
and it's good the Cowboys are like Man U
I see that I see that who would be the
Liverpool
here as he sends this one away
oh nice okay
they had no one there to stop it hits it
the eight but it carries on gotta Titans
go for a Touchback who do the Titans uh
you know it's got a new QB right in the
draft at the center of it all of course
you guys got you guys have a future uh
QB I think on uh
is it Malik
[Applause]
Singletary to get the driver I feel like
Malik like fell in the draft
hadn't been the Titans
looked like he was trying to buy the
game not for the gamer to talk about
football kindness no I if I buy the game
it is to play of course it's just I just
loved everything about football so that
kind of explains
um and just ran him down like my why why
I like put up with Madden every year
more or less
when it comes to something like
for digs
oh
that was gorgeous I should have mashed
it off so there is the big wow he can
throw it as deep as anybody and that was
an absolute laser wow
[Applause]
really good starting here's First and
Ten throwing there but wow okay so since
I ran to the weak side
that like hindered my past there
interesting I've never had that kind of
a debuff before in space it would have
been a good time for his first Carry of
the game and
[Applause]
[Applause]
I think that's the default that I have
right now
okay I can mess with all Madden probably
gonna get destroyed and usually when I
play with my friends we said it's all
Madden that's the default but um because
of the new like skill passing or
whatever I thought All-Pro was a better
um
balance just run it
um I thought it was a better balance you
know what I mean because you know guys
this is the Xbox version yes yes it is
around the board first here this
afternoon
feels fans razza
typically time kick that's a burst for
today extra point by bass NFL Blitz ah
yeah you want to talk about Nostalgia
NFL Blitz for sure I am
I wrote a comment on my video I did an
everything to Know video on teamspotch
about uh it's like a general video it's
not really an opinion video it's just
like hey here's when the game comes out
here's what's new here's what platforms
it's on it's kind of to inform you if
you are interested in buying the game
and in that video I wrote a comment
about NFL Street so that was you know
NFL Street was like my NFL Blitz you
know I just I love playing NFL Street so
much I wish with all my heart that they
would bring beginning of a game that
game back
um but they won't I know they won't
because they have the yard in Madden now
and I do not like the yard it's like a
shell
y
um it's like a shell of what NFL Street
was you know what I mean in a negative
way that's what all the guys are looking
for it's not realistic number
yeah I I can see that man the defense is
kind of weird I mean it's AI too you
know what I mean if I was playing
against someone
uh online especially someone good I
strongly doubt it would let the uh it
would let that much space
overall best Madden my favorite Madden I
think was Madden I want to say 07
um it was the one with um Vince uh with
Vince Young on the cover
all right I I love that Madden it wasn't
for any particular reason like you know
it's not like oh Madden 04 had Michael
Vick and I was like the best or Madden
10 did this or that he was just Madden
07 was like the first real Madden that I
owned and they get the first you know
you never really forget your first so to
speak yours was 08 yeah that was uh
Brett Favre I think
yards as they've got the connection
working his second catch in a row first
down hey man I can tell you the AL
appears if you want to tell you all the
covers for Imagine off the top of my
head from O7 I think you know what I
mean again
[Applause]
he is tackled inside the 40 not quite to
the 35. they'll get 13 yards for the
second player yeah five was 0-9 oh it
was 0-9 then who was 08 keep all the
receivers alive and to play wait maybe
I'm thinking about it maybe make sure
you keep your eyes moving
so nine ten was halamalu and Larry Fitz
again
um
11.
11 was um Drew Brees uh 12 was
hilariously 12 was the Browns running
back we had one good year and then like
disappeared
to the touchdown drive against him a few
minutes
[Music]
Calvin Johnson and they're putting
together 14. as a response was uh Adrian
Peterson 15 was Richard Sherman
no not at all they didn't really I think
I remember 16 in their proper places and
not allowing installed and then 17
might have been no 18 was grown yeah I
don't remember so I think 18 was wrong
uh maybe Brady was one of them 16 17.
the 19th Aviation
20 was
no I'm [ __ ]
yeah I'm losing it a little bit
yeah 14 was known as Madden 25.
um
yeah you guys still have to remind me
who the covers were for 18 and 19. oh
that's in good
um Harris Campbell obj thank you that's
right 16 was obj he had the one-handed
cash over the cover that's right
March their partner took him a lot yeah
15 was Sherman 16 LBJ
at one point
was on the cover of it was 18. you had
by the offense uh Brady and Mahone
21 might have just been Brady and then
20
was just my homes I think there was
there's a lot of double dipping with
those two I feel like so I'll leave it
now is they kick it away oh I said one
quarter huh I'm already in the second
quarter okay let me just throw a bomb in
all so we'll find someone
to find some other um
[Applause]
so here come the bills out for their
second drive and they'll be looking to
build with a nice drive last time a
drive
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
you know a quarterback saying hey I'm
going to throw this as far as I can and
hope you run under it mission
accomplished on play action Allen
decision passing there you go nice nice
sir all right
new teams new teams that was good that
was a good drive though it was very fast
two big bombs uh okay
it is 425 I've got about probably about
40 minutes or so let me bear with me
chat let's let's hop into uh some other
modes real quick and I'll go back into
play now in just a sec just so I can you
know cover the gauntlet show you guys
some of the other stuff here
um and we'll see what we got so I'm
gonna hop into let's hop into Ultimate
Team let's see
what I got
slim dollar the graphics are not that
good is this the old Xbox or the new one
this is the new one this is the series
uh X however
um
oh hey that's the fuel pass I was
telling you guys about earlier uh 10 000
coins nice
um but there is a there is a Fidelity
mode I could I could turn that off uh
turn that on if you guys want but then
the the frame rate
gets like chucked down to 30.
and that's kinda you know but
if if it's what you guys prefer I could
I could uh just flip the switch you know
what I mean
Giants Titans for the next uh one I can
keep that in mind yeah let's do it
what do we got
oh Jerry Judy okay
can ignore him on principle Andre Vince
John Kaminski Jeron Harmon Justin fields
and Hunter Camp employer all right
dismiss all of that all a bunch of
average ass players I'm not going to
check out the marketplace because I do
not want to pay money uh
damn they gave me all Raiders and they
brought them down to 69 that feels
it was kind of funny and kind of bad
um Mission what do we got
unlock your starter team beat this
challenge to unlock your starter team
okay
are you guys
um
okay hold on really quick so why is Judy
so low so first of all when you start
Ultimate Team they purposefully cap a
lot of the players rankings
because you're supposed to level them up
and when you get like a card let's say
like I get a Derek Carr power-up card or
whatever
um you're supposed to level it up by
doing all these missions and investing a
bunch of
freaking coins and other BS into women
then eventually you get them up however
full disclosure ultimate team's a cash
grab and if you go into like if you try
to get a team that's like 99 and you try
to do it without paying good luck it's
gonna take you forever and it's usually
not worth it in my mind
um of course your mileage can vary some
people like it some people don't for me
personally whenever I log into Madden
it's not to sink money into Ultimate
Team it's just a pop into exhibition I
do like the fantasy draft sometimes you
could do that for free you don't really
have to like play anything I'll do the
fantasy draft and just like mess around
I find that to be a lot of fun
um but it is what it is in fact actually
I wonder if they still have that because
I don't know if they do let's check out
the field passes actually because that
this is new this is new to Madden 23
Madam swimsuit does not have this
so you have three kinds right now we've
got headliners
okay we've got competitive which ends in
two weeks uh taking the competition head
to head in Solo battles objectives
earned level up earn Pax coins this pass
refreshes every two weeks okay
uh this looks like it's 60 days two
months so this is the whole season's
Headliners in season one
and looks like we already hit level
three just from playing those exhibition
matches earlier so what did I end up
getting we got rewards track okay we got
a coach John Madden item
uh history team to Ultimate okay it's
just like a little uh
oh thank you I guess you can put in your
little binder you know
we got the 10 000 coins of course and
level four looks like we get a strategy
item to improve the stats of a left
tackle
you get a 70 plus overall player at
level five
get a game day pack a level six okay two
thousand coins okay so you know it's
like a battle pass
stuff makes sense
at least at least they have this man I
mean I I hate I hate having to pay money
uh after you've already bought a game so
I I appreciate battle passes and it
seems like this this battle pass is free
usually you have to pay like 10 bucks
for a battle pass
um but it seems like this one is just
given which is nice
so
I get some uniforms customize uniforms
it's at the end usually the best stuff
is at the end of the uh
the battle pass
the other thing too is you know you
gotta uh see how progression works
because a progression is like you know
if it stops then what's the point of
grinding all the way to level 61 or
whatever if it takes like three months
of game time or some [ __ ] so
um I will try the Fidelity mode Cody
from earlier you asked I'll give that a
shot what's this boo Ultimate Team I I
hear you
um
we've developed this Gamers when opening
up virtual card packs is taking
precedence that we're actually playing
the game shake my head I can dude hey
yeah I feel that really I do you know in
NFL Street there would be stuff like
this like challenge modes and you would
play the game to get the points to
upgrade your own team and sometimes you
could even like snipe people from uh
other uh professional teams so you could
get like Rod Woodson you could get a
Jerry Rice and stuff like that and it
was nice stuff was more fun you know
especially the thing that I don't like
about Madden Ultimate Team is that it
you can't carry your team over this is
all going to be gone when Madden 24
comes out next year right so it's like
if you spend even a dime on Ultimate
Team you have to understand that it's
going to be gone and it's like I don't
know how I feel about that to be to be
completely honest with you guys so
let's see
because I would actually love that sorry
Ultimate Team how to Landers team
affinity and Marketplace
uh just liner
trade headliner is my team binder rename
team competitive
no content no content no content no
constant content it's probably not live
yet so
all right so that's uh
Ultimate Team we'll get out of there
there's not much to do there
online Pro Bowl Madden Legacy game
all right you all get to pick what do we
what do we do next to wrap off the uh
the rest of this
oh someone said Fidelity mode right let
me do that real quick
shouldn't be that hard gotta find the
setting somewhere
not there maybe it's in another setting
rip to John Madden indeed sir
give game controls oh graphics
an exhibition is there a way to get a
classic teams like classic rosters you
mean
um
I don't know uh we could hop into the
Madden Legacy game which is like the Pro
Bowl
uh all right I just swapped it to image
quality so hopefully you guys can notice
a difference
um well let's hop into the the Madden
Legacy game and see if it's they got
some classic players sometimes they do
that
so if you do Pro Bowl I'm sure it's
current roster so do Legacy it's got to
be like old school
folks oh yeah yeah yeah here we go
wow they got Junior R.I.P to Junior
Deion Sanders Randy Moss Brett Favre all
right we do an AFC we do an NFC
here's there's some Legends on both
sides y'all
uh that's hard for me to pick that's
hard for me to pick whatever comment I
see first pop up that's who I'm picking
versus NFC or ABC first
there's gonna be a bit of a delay by the
time you guys hear this so I'll see NFC
all right there we go boom
Justin was the quickest on the draw on
the YouTube chat so we go in NFC
throw some bombs as Brett Favre
even teams quarter accelerated Cloud
yeah all this stuff is fine let's do
simulation true to player and team
ratings Authenticator
looks like we got NFC fans anyway so hey
looks like I picked up this is a special
presentation of oh maybe I should have
skipped that you guys could have seen
the intro that's special presentation
that was just a habit One Time For Old
Times what do you say we play some
football as we are Devin Hester
yo return King
Chicago fans are gonna love that
so it's the NFC stars who will get the
ball first and charge all right y'all we
want to be past heavy run heavy you want
me to coach on each sideline I was gonna
say do you want me to like try to win
for real but like maybe yeah she was
trying to establish a foothold in the
NFL and on the cusp of doing it very
successful yeah you think back to that
period those early days as the coach of
the Raiders the late 60s
Jerry Rice
ahead of his time the Raiders are one of
the first teams to have mini camps one
of the first to film practice because he
wanted to practice coaching as much as
he could in his teams they were
successful around the start
I got to learn how to lob the ball with
a Precision passing I think everything
I've been throwing is bullets so
let's try a lot how far
yes
[Applause]
so as we mentioned at the top let's take
you through the life of John Beck and
you know it's very fitting that we're
here back in the Bay Area not just
because John so associated with Raiders
there's the lot also because this is
[Applause]
to uh
I bet you wound up playing tackled the
University of Oregon and later Cal Poly
San Luis at this call Clinton welding up
in 1958 he was a 21st round draft pick
it's gorgeous uh you know fun fact about
that pass I literally did tap the button
and it still read it as a touch pass so
I don't know if it's like you literally
just have to be like set the tone like
that you know or or what but if the
people behind the curtain that they gave
us I'll give it a shot yeah
I think you're exactly right about that
never Lobby
and that's gonna be caught there you go
y'all see there's some good plays
[Applause]
and a c takes it off
gameplay wise like those passes they
felt kind of kind of massage but then
again you're also like working with rank
99
[Applause]
that tends to mask a lot of your
mistakes
[Applause]
to finalize things off the graphics look
a little better like lighting wise
shading wise but the textures are still
weird EA was never good at doing hair
you know
like the hair on on Madden looks really
weird
following the touchdown here's Anderson
that shot looks nice on my monitor right
now that looks pretty uh pretty solid no
run back here for Hall and this will
come out Chris says how is the game
game's fine you know it's nothing
um
you'd feel just just at home playing
Madden 22 so you feel just at home you
know what I mean like your career um
it's nice to have the Z roster but you
can also download
gameplay
there's still some weird glitchy GPS
from time to time and I've mentioned it
a couple of times I'm still not fully
used to the passing the new house but
when it works it works well Super Bowls
the Dolphins won two and we're a
Mainstay in the playoffs the Colts were
tough the Broncos came on late and went
to a Super Bowl themselves but against
home field coaches John Madden took like
five people to bring them down
two that's pretty incredible he's ready
for a factor each and every year but
Charles you mentioned coach was a 21st
round draft pick back in 1958 was the
Philadelphia Eagles who selected it but
unfortunately for John knee problems
they just continued to dog him he was
hurt in his first training camp actually
never saw the field as a player in the
NFL but it was still during his time sir
the more than three trade slots are you
talking about franchisements there have
been changes to uh trading and
franchisement I believe it's trading or
not no I don't know if it's trading
um but they did change scouting in like
free agency
[Music]
um and future head coaching we have a
really really good breakdown of all the
franchise mode changes that our reviewer
Mark Delaney wrote If you go to
gamestop.com and or if you even just go
to Google you type in like Gamespot
franchise mode changes Madden 23 or
something like that uh his article will
pop up and he breaks it down some really
really well off the top of my head I
know that franchise mode changed how the
agency works and the way that both Ai
and real people can try to uh pick up
free agents and what like factors into
the decision to sign the service
which is to you know I don't say it
often but to EA's credit I I respect it
because a lot of fans were saying you're
putting out the same game and you're not
changing franchise you're putting out
the same games
you're taking away franchise features
you know what I mean
um and it seems like they just became
really focused on it a lot of their
previews
and they focus on franchise
um which to me says they're kind of
getting the hint they're seeing all the
bad reviews
so
um
excited to see the changes I have three
people on my my DMV there's three
linemen stopping him just for uh to
throw it away
guy to bump this away on fourth down
he steps into this one and this is a
rocket and they'll play keep away from
the returner is this one some people
said is way better than why are they
flashing the NFC offense coming out here
um so people said it's way better than
22 that's why you're asking yeah it
makes sense you know I can see it being
a Improvement on 22. if you are into
franchise mode and if you are smiling
feel good about like the talking field
sense animations
why is accelerated clock still a problem
what do you mean you can turn it off if
you don't like it but I don't know what
you mean by it it's a problem I like the
accelerator
keeps things running a little smoothly I
don't want to play like simulation or
anything like that it was always a game
[Applause]
it'll be Sanders
and he is out of bounds able to get it
uh it's an ultimate edition three days
early yeah if you have Ultimate Edition
you can't play three days early but we
don't have Ultimate Edition I haven't
bought the game I just have EA players
try these numbers on for size since 10
seasons is a head coach the Raiders won
their division seven times they finished
second the other three times and he
became the youngest coach to amass a
hundred career regular season victories
and is still to this day the franchise
leader and wins and when you think about
it that's where that rivalry with Delta
City really
as did the expression commitment to
Excellence yeah I know if you give a
straight yes or no in the tree of slots
probably means no the reason why I can't
give a straight yes or no is because
actually I don't know like I don't know
off the top of my head
um but like I said go check out uh name
a few go check out Mark Delaney's uh
article because he she knows he's
probably written it in his uh guide and
all the franchisement changes
[Applause]
and big Ben Davidson so many great
players so many great memories
now on Third and long they'll look to
throw
he's gonna float this one deep right
side oh and unable to connect do you get
the ultimate edition with EA play no
definitely not I don't think you do it I
think um you could get a discount if you
want to buy it but EA play does not give
you the full license for the game down
for Madden 23.
um
EA play only gives you a discount on any
Madden purchases and we'll probably give
you Madden 22 for free now that it's old
you know what I mean usually when EA
plays brings the pool like FIFA Madden
and shell games
for free it ends up being near the end
coach's favorites
the boy coach always admired the way
science is broken especially his ability
I don't know maybe you're leaving the
stream that's why you said it but I
appreciate you joining
The Vibes man
he's a cool guy
let me tell you there's no one calmer
into pockets and I know that coach has a
great appreciation for Tom uh I
mentioned Enfield Street a couple of
times have any of you guys played
I've never got like uh we had a lot of
NFL Blitz in this game uh fans we had a
lot of 2K NFL fans Tom Brady call but if
anyone's playing NFL Street I need to
know 41 because I love that game and
low-key I might [ __ ] I don't know man
maybe this weekend I'll like download an
emulator since then play the like
PS2 yeah NFL Street
[Applause]
on what resolution is this um so
on the monitor that I'm looking at right
now it's 4K
4K 4K full Ultra HD all that [ __ ] on the
stream I think it's 1080p I think that's
what we're putting it out I don't think
we could uh output 4K
that's just like really intense and
Brandon but uh you're probably watching
them in 1080P the game Feed is 4K
Fidelity mode so it's like all Graphics
more choppier frame rate if I switch it
to Performance mode the graphics
resolution will be downscaled I think to
1080. but you'll be playing at like 60
seconds
[Applause]
yes the Immaculate Reception game Franco
Harris grabbing the ball
says the game looks good and hey well
there you go game winning score to give
this a 13-7 victory you know it's not
for everyone but anyone who
it's always nice when you know if you uh
if you enjoy it because that's what
matters at the end of the day is fun
right no one wants to play a game that
they don't want right
they'll stick with the passing game as
he looks to throw yeah he'll find home
now the ANC going to take a timeout it's
there skill base passing hard I think so
I think it's hard
um I'm still not fully adjusted to it
you know I've been playing now I
downloaded the game at around 1 30 2
o'clock I uh this is West Coast time by
the way uh 1 32 o'clock and I um
played a couple of practice games before
I booted up the stream so I could like
you know figure out what was going on I
did the train still base passing uh
there's two variants of skill based
passing that threw me off he just
couldn't find it and throw it too yeah
you know it's caused a lot of uh a lot
of interceptions basically but there
have been also some really cool throws
that felt like oh man I threw into
triple coverage like an idiot but it
made it because the accuracy was so
precise
other than that everything else feels uh
you know
[Applause]
[Applause]
they always talk about animations
they're always like yo I've got you know
x amount of animations that we've been
mooc happening we've got a thousand
animations ten thousand animations
facial animations this animation and I
never I never noticed whoa
um I've never noticed animations it
happens too fast you know when you're
playing you're focused on the gameplay
always appreciated the ferociousness
with which number 84 attack
so hard if if like animations
[Music]
still says is it is a gameplay mechanic
that this actually feels different
[Applause]
it changes when you decide to pass it
changes the type of passes you're making
that is a fundamental change everything
else same old sandwich
let's
this challenge
and they line up now for what will
likely be the last by the more expensive
version do you get to play earlier yes
if you buy the all-matter Edition you
can play it earlier but the game comes
out on the 19th which is like
not that far away so at this point you
know unless if you're like I die hard
Madden fan
he's gonna swing this dude I mean like
why else would you uh and he knocks the
ball away would you want to pay that
much more money just to play one three
days earlier
but for now we present a very special
tribute to the man of the hour narrated
by Trey Mosley boy Charles yeah that's
that is really well done coach was
something else wasn't he I must they
have done that on the field
he loved the game are there speed
settings in Madden 23 how do you mean
like like doubling the speed tripling
the speed making everything super fast
everything he does like an art like like
a Super Street Fighter two turbo or some
[ __ ] yeah
second half fourth coming from Oakland
[Applause]
waiting now on first down
well the NFC pressure
[Applause]
coming in hard there on the blitz and he
gets it we need big head mode oh my gosh
I do remember big penos look to make
amends on a second yes we do
John D on Twitch absolutely
um
that's personal though because I hate
Brady he's taken down
and literally will never apologize
for roughing the passer if it's Brady
someone once told me you'll never
understand how much I hate Steph Curry
because you're a warrior someone told me
that once and
and
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
coach
[Applause]
oh if you mean in terms of like everyone
hating him that makes sense
I don't know if y'all ever saw that 30
30 of I hate Christian Leitner it's
really good it's a really good doctor
and he's teamed up with Pat Summerall
and that pairing ultimately would go on
to be one of the most influential in
sports broadcasters epic Kingdom says
amazes me that he just could play this
every year I mean you know it's games
like together not every person is meant
to play every game and not every game is
meant to be played by every person you
have the sequels coming out all the time
you've got you Halos you've got new
Assassins Creeds you've got any Call of
Duties
um those are geared towards particular
Gamers that want a particular experience
now do I think that Madden is a little
Shameless
um EA in general is a little Shameless
with their pay to win modes yes I do it
I think that could be better
um about it and they should make the
option of freely playing ultimate teams
less of a grinds you know what I mean
I don't I don't judge people if they
play uh if they like matters because
that's them you know what I mean it's
totally fine I play Call of Duty I play
War zones a lot like Destiny these are
games
like not Everyone likes it's not meant
for everyone but it is what it is and
now it's a stable for all analysts to
have I do appreciate that we are kind of
going back to the old classic almost
like Golden Era of gaming with story
based campaigns you know what I mean
like
um the unique devil make cries and the
metal gear solids and the final
fantasies of the uh gaming space it's
nice to kind of
have those
series
you know what I mean it doesn't mean cry
five it was a lot of fun years ago we've
got a lot of like historic games that
are um
[Music]
development that are coming out and then
you have original IPS there's a lot of
good footballers
uh this year and next year but I'm
really excited for Brady gonna try and
throw just a good year
scenes they're able to convert on third
down to that sets up a first degree as
we as we approach the end of the year
pretty sure Eldon ring is going to be
the the heavy favorite to be the uh Game
of the Year Contender but you can
curious what other games you guys have
been playing that are like 10 out of 10
so they're both that you really like
also back to the sports talk to be the
golden basketball you have to be great
at both ends of the Court you know
there's a place that's why you've got
your star out there to throw the ball to
them they did simply saying we don't
care what coverage you put out there oh
this is gold oh damn
yeah
that's that's big shadow that is a
really healthy way to look at gaming
matter makes some people happy not
perfect and definitely push for
improvements
absolutely absolutely Mike my dude
absolutely
um and you know everyone that is in this
chat right now I know for a fact that
all of you guys love games
straight up there was not a single
person in this chat that hates videos
because if you do then you're clearly on
the wrong stream right
after that ask for what games we all
like preference
I think that there are certain troubling
Trends in gaming uh blue boxes uh it's
kind of predatory microtransaction stuff
that is a little we did get a little
upsetting
um I'm also not a fan of the 90s and two
things you know ship a game incomplete
and we'll just update it and Patch it
and have the DLC man I don't really like
that either
yeah
at the end of the day we've got really
passionate people working on games as
all walks of life of all different uh
backgrounds and he's got really
passionate Gamers you know what I mean
you got communities in every single game
everyone is so excited to just share
what they like and play with friends
that's the way it's got to be and he got
his wish
[Applause]
man I think I just got to be wholesome
through the 90s because John himself
the more wholesome I Am The more
precisionasses I've made in the 2020s
you know let's all be positive guys you
know hey 2020 was never the end of the
world we're all having a great time here
and there the touchdowns
and the NFC has retaken the lead
the plenty of you can't you just saying
yo so one Mission got to wear Ragnarok I
just Platinum God of War
um I think like two weeks ago I played
God of War for the first time earlier in
the month I could not put that game down
man could not put it down
um so good so good I know I'm three
years late it's so good and I'm ready
for rack absolutely
I got my PS5
although I think we have other folks on
staff that are really passionate about
the game they might get first crack at
covering content but if I'm not you know
making videos for it I'm definitely
going to be playing it uh on launch day
like I love God of War and I'm so
excited touch down here's Anderson to
kick it away you have to be turned into
a live stream yeah yeah absolutely if
you turn into a live stream you have to
be a game
without a doubt
[Applause]
we got a two minute warning can we hold
off a touchdown in a two-point converter
trying to finish this one off we're back
to Oakland after this the AFC for the
football fans in chat who is your
favorite player of all times and who is
your favorite player currently on your
favorite team
[Applause]
and I think that that's exactly so you
can have like a Hall of Famer that you
really like it doesn't have to be your
favorite team or not it could just be
like you know someone that was iconic uh
Joe Montana
oh Charles Woodson died you know uh
player he finds his man complete but
then if you also have a currency
he's like that
[Music]
money
[Applause]
when you talk about making winning plays
that is a winning play at this that's
the first tip for me that I've been
talking way too much
because most people think winning plays
or the offense trying to get it Jerry
Rice all the time George Kittle is your
current player
found a way to make a play on that
George Kittle is a dog George Kittle's
got that dog in him I love Kittle even
as a Raider fan I love kiddos so much
man that guy is an absolute monster and
Jerry Rice also hopped to the Raiders
you know at the end so but he is Jerry
Rice is like definitely one of the boats
Marshall fault hell yeah
Aaron Donald Aaron Donaldson
I don't know if anyone here subscribes
to johnboy johnboy Media he mostly
covers uh baseball
very very very amazing funny
um
he sometimes will do breakdowns in like
lip sync readings of
um iconic moments and other sports and
he did one of Aaron Donald lifting up
Devonta Freeman during the scuffle just
straight up lifting this dude like a
baby off the uh the turf and it was so
funny
yeah he finished his speech by saying
today
[Laughter]
if sauce got anything uh going for him
for the Jets man getting after him
enforce the incompletion can you do a
360 cut I think you can put this one
away um but there are like 360. that is
much like the running back but I don't
know what the motion is maybe it's like
a spin or something
I can try it I'll just like spam the
right sticks
when I get the ball back down back from
that last Drive in particular if they
can bounce back at the quarterback
position Charles after throwing their
first interception with LC I remember
two things about LT I remember uh it was
very funny ESPN uh this is ESPN
advertisement with him trying to put
mail
and the mailboxes of all the employees
and you can't see [ __ ] as an advisor
very funny
um and I also remember I think it might
have been a Gatorade commercial or a
Nike commercial or something and it was
LT like running doing Cubs and then
doing a signature little like balls
flick uh
super iconic
Jerome Bettis the bus
hell yeah
to throw his Brady
uh someone ordered all mad Edition don't
have axes yet you should have access you
should have uh Early Access maybe it
goes live at like 9pm tonight
you know uh I'm honestly not sure but
all Madden Edition will give you early
access that is the whole um
about it is if you pre-order the game
now Brady get all access
now a desperation throw deep downfield
and he's got it it's coming for a
touchdown what
[Applause]
Charles that drive that sucks
[Applause]
we just need a field goal that's it
[Applause]
ability to throw
um
I think I think yes
[Applause]
ready to begin their next drive here the
NFC offense
[Applause]
again
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
is what it is that was a close game
though I got E8 yes sir that's a good
way to put it
getting EA
all right let me hop into uh okay it
might be a little over time let me hop
into a quick exhibition match we'll do
one last quarter I'm gonna try that 360
cut and we're just gonna let's do some
myth busting let's just do the dumbest
plays see what we can get uh going on
and then I'll sign off
all righty let's get going
like Spangles I'm gonna do that because
I think I don't know if you were here
from the beginning Gotham but I
distinctly remember someone requesting
uh Vikings and Bengals so I owe you that
well let's do it let's see if I can do
some Bangles
um
where you at
there we go and Viking
there we go
boom
yeah who do you defend you defend Alvin
cook or do you find Justin Jefferson man
because they
shoot they are both
really good
yeah I got them it was you right yeah I
remember there you go oh this one's for
you buddy
uh
uh yeah let's [ __ ] around someone wanted
a um
360 cut try and mess with this see what
we can do
if anyone else happens to just know if
it's like the right stick do I just
today's classes
and it's coming right up on Madden NFL
23.
was it the great says we love Madden
we're gonna get it every year bro all
right hey y'all we found the bot we
found them you found the bot in chat in
the queen I'm just playing bro you do
you if you you love Madden hell yeah you
joined the right stream although maybe a
little late
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
this was a funny stream for sure
like that
they strike the driver court and forget
about finding a lane he barely had time
to had Delvin cooking up in one year and
it was the year that I really wanted him
he was like the best RV that's a really
alert defense there because they saw the
heavy ball come in from the offense that
man's got glasses I'm always scared
especially for their defense
[Applause]
[Laughter]
dude I really do cousins people that are
open about that they're like yo I play
Madden I play this [ __ ] every year I
love it like this game you know there
are people that love fighting games and
only fighting games there are people
that love uh
you know Cod I play fortnite so who am I
to talk you know what I mean like so
[ __ ] get some Strokes for different
folks as long as you're having fun
[Applause]
that was that was like five literally
like I went live and then five seconds
later I just later
God damn man
[Applause]
cousins gives way to cook
I'm the player you might have noticed in
the last play I'm the player that spams
b Circle if you're on Playstation to
just like quickly get to the nearest
Defender but it never works it always
goes to like you know the outside
Defender and I just dive completely
so funny
uh we'll constantly by streaming the
song Xbox series X
I got the uh the Old Brick right here I
love it I love how serious I also love
the PS5 combination
[Applause]
a little bit
oh no no show
um I don't know if you can do face scans
I think face scans is a 2K thing wizard
um
I'm not sure if past Madden's had it
then there you go but the only time I
ever messed up uh are the only time I
ever did face scans was
um
so
so they'll get another shot hey cheers
Adam thank you yeah that was a good pick
wasn't me it was definitely in the CPU
but we take those
one out he'll just go down to a knee and
oh that's right 360 seconds
oh [ __ ] right after I scored not bad
okay
oh I see what you're saying like you
want me to check how the DBS look
themselves like in the game not like uh
like you oh what a cut
[Applause]
you want me to like see how the DBS look
uh in the game
like individually or whatever I can do
that uh especially after this game just
remind me yeah
I'll hop in we can take a look at how
the Clippers we always know that he is
there is he understands what it off yeah
a great job with scouting prior to the
game all right 360 cut I gotta remember
I'm gonna go for this okay
as soon as we get a call back
to pick up the first down and move the
chains
[Applause]
they're in man-to-man maybe needs some
safety help I would say that'd be a good
idea double team him somehow I'm gonna
have to make someone else beat me rather
than let him shred my defense I was rude
for y'all too first Junior
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
another nice gain 13 yards that time and
another first down I tell you what it
looks like he's shaking opposite pick
six just fine does tackling feel
different kind of
um and when I say kind of I mean I a lot
of my tackles are getting broken you
know what I mean
a lot of my tackles are being broken but
I never I almost never press X to tackle
I almost always
um
is the trial expired when you're not
online I think it's just game time so I
think it's it's 10 cumulative hours
so if I log off and I exit the game I
don't just hit menu and back out because
a lot of a lot of these new next-gen
consoles they have the games kind of
running in the background so make sure
you like exit exit if that makes sense
I think your time is safe
but just to be specifically I'm not
entirely sure how the magnusia of all of
this works
uh the music Johnson YouTube says does
the gameplay feel like 22 or 21 at all
yeah for sure I mean every
every Madden game at its core
feels like the old patterns before right
there there's nothing that's like a holy
[ __ ] this is radically different the
only thing that feels different is um
and obviously he transmitted that too
sir we gotta let the Vikings score so I
can put the ball back and try this uh
360 cut so
now as they kick it away
Fields it right around the goal line
and up to about to 26. interesting there
was an a button that popped up there
I don't know
burrow could have won comeback player of
the year last season simply for his
statistics did the Bengals have the
white helmets they might there was a
there was a bunch of different little uh
helmets I just remember the game sound
is louder than me I I'm just speaking
low so here let me lower the game sound
a little bit more uh apologies about
that
you guys compare my uh beautiful voice
instead and he had them less than two
minutes away
360. keep an eye on
Joe the Super Bowl title to Cincinnati
in the near future let me let me run a
uh
20 seconds
someone said what bot uh it's just you
know there it might have been deleted by
now but on my uh chat field it was like
uh a Spam site
spammed like five uh comments on my feet
so
it might be gone by now all right
the defense get a blanket the fields
Nixon on the toss right
that was just a spin move that was not a
360 card or whatever
L2 for 360 cut It's Gonna Leave You sure
I'm not gonna lateral it all of a sudden
am I
sure hey let me try and get this uh
let's try and get this first down and
then I'll I'll try uh I'll try uh left
trigger
some of these runs while they haven't
been successful they may be successful
later on
[Applause]
I know I know left bumper for sure is
lateral and I'm never gonna press that
again uh I'll try I'll try I'll see
because right trigger is to like burst
the speed
uh yeah and then I wonder if you press
LT then do you spin or something so
we'll see
you swallowed up right I held LT that
time
and I um
I held out to you that time and I did
like a a circle on my stick so I love
that description
made the flag and he couldn't even get
going holding LT he like dipped his
shoulder in a little bit first half as
they're gonna stop
him that's a big loss of three and it
brings up third down the running Lanes
have definitely not been there for him
here in the first half and I don't think
it's all been his fault his offensive
mind hasn't given him much space
see no difference in the last six NFL
games yeah
did I make someone fumble yet yeah a few
times
LT so hold the left trigger
I gotta Break Free on the ground mix it
again
LT was a hard cut that's what it was I
don't know if that was a 360. get him
down by holding the LT he did a hard cap
so as they take it over
probably check
let's look at the options real quick
there's got to be some kind of
controls setting right
skill level more oh game controls let's
see if there's 360 cut on here
wise hurdle of course exits the slide or
give up or dive spin uh stiff arm down
is a dead leg up is the truck oh 360 cut
okay okay so it's not a 360 spin it's a
360 cut control so that's what it is
okay
um I I was thinking it was a 360 spin
you know what I mean okay so 360 cut
control Okay cool so yeah it is it is
left trigger so you were right uh Jay
thank you for that
um
all right yeah let me let me [ __ ] with
it more
I seemed like he'd like dipped his
shoulder in a couple of a couple of
times you know what I mean
uh I'm just rolling on on Fourth Downs
here we go I feel old as [ __ ] now you
play Madden 95 yes sir
at least you're an OG bro
that was Precision passing you know was
able to do I mean that was weird
animation right there but that was
Precision passing just right on the
outside led him well enough
that felt distinctly
um
all right let's go back to the runs
let's try some 360 uh cuts
I mean it's okay to end drives and kicks
right you know we've heard that from
different guys before remember it kicks
either a punt right field goal or a
point after touchdown it's okay to end
it in a kick a lot of scrimmage the 31
now on First and Ten
running left it's mixing
and he's going to get this didn't really
notice much but apparently it happened
they get 10 more there pay to play
Madden only only in uh ultimately I
agree try to do an inside run to bounce
it oh it's good good good good good
Lorenzo good idea
Super Smash yeah we'll see we'll see if
it like bounces it off the the you know
uh linemen are off the tackle let's give
it a try back to mixing
consecutive
um
just move them down the field with his
number is called the way he's running it
I keep going back to him
all right that he's brought down just
outside
they'll get to the line here but
remember it's also third down
third down
love is coming
11 11 11.
they give to Mixie to try to pick it up
and he will have the first down
touchdown
I don't I don't really run the ball that
often for me to be able to tell you guys
if it um
if it feels different you know what I
mean than like pass Cuts or whatever
but
yeah let me let me set the defense or
offensive Focus to uh running on the
inside
maybe it'll it'll promote more so we'll
see inside Charles Davis
yeah it's hard for me to be like yo the
360 cut is like legendary because I just
don't have that expertise to be able to
like use it properly if that makes sense
um but but I think you're right it's
meant to help you cut with uh and follow
your blockers you know what I mean the
problem is that
I don't know if it's if if you just
press it does it cut in the opposite
direction or do you lead with your left
stick of which direction you cut you
know what I mean so if I'm running that
way and then I want to cut that way do I
like flick the stick when I press the
left trigger well uh here we go
their teams hey we're starting to Brand
Corey Campbell John Madden you say is a
legendary coach yes sir one of the
greatest
Jason who blockers you their actual
Simonson block this year when running
the ball or the same 22-0 lineman I
don't know man I don't know blockers are
weird man and uh the trenches
[Applause]
a little bit and they struggled to get
him running on the ground in the first
some people you have to lead it uh what
do you mean like like I lead the
direction and then I cut I could see
that
[Music]
right back
I mean they got the box stacked up or
whatever
[Applause]
Nixon
if he didn't stumble I might that would
have been a perfect time for me
there but it'll be down now
and he's hoping that that's a precursor
of a big second half
they'll run with Nixon
[Applause]
all right back to you trying the 360 cut
let's see
he's gonna take this
little Shake
second and seven
again it's mixing that he is going to be
stopped by the DVD
s and they're going to hurry back to the
line now
mix it up the middle
oh
damn he bobbled that [ __ ]
I don't know how it makes him cough that
up but like
flipped out
maybe got going a little
sometimes that's the danger of going to
that type of a system is that you take
care of things as well as you would in
normal situations you get going so fast
heat up
and you don't take care of the ball and
we just all want to hit the ground
absolutely we saw what can happen
they're able to get the past the
25. 40 yards rushing now on eight
carries for him so far sometimes it's
hard to believe but there are times this
game is about patience isn't it has had
the game be expected but that run there
that may get him going I was just going
to say maybe that gives him a little all
right I'm gonna let you guys decide we
can either play this game out or I can
end early and look at some of the things
you might you guys might have wanted to
see like season pass or field scans or
things like that unfortunately I will
not have time to do both
I've already kind of overstayed my
welcome with the Stream
all for the sake of content of course
let me know how you guys are uh uh
knife field but he wasn't able to get
him down
but in Patriots they were able to grab
him at the line oh I shouldn't let him
get any further downfield damn this is
what he's doing uh
let me see the jerseys I shot a couple
of jerseys earlier but I can show you
some more a good pick up there 789 wants
nothing to do with this he wants us to
quit
as we've been together but I think we
could at least put this one in our top
five that was a determined Galaxy
get some more uh comments in here and
all from the shotgun it's cousin leaning
towards it
dancing to his left
and he'll just Chuck this one up into
row G it's incomplete
again
[Applause]
Twitches thinks the Broncos are going to
go uh Gonna Go Far this year
[Applause]
he wants to see the Bengals jerseys for
sure bro
to have all right I'll do I'll do one
more drive on offense
let's see if I can get that 360 cut
going and maybe just throw a bomb and
then uh
I'll bail early and I'll show you guys
what the what the jerseys for the
Bengals looks like and uh maybe see if I
can get like somebody scans
let me see what uh some of the some of
the players looks like now Joseph tease
it up to kick off following the
touchdown
how would we find the face scans would
it be under rosters Maybe
I would assume so much happening on the
return is he'll get this to about the
23.
[Music]
but they've got to take care of the
football and do better here on this
possession it's certainly been a tough
stretch partner for both of those units
and they kind of put their defense oh
hurry up options
[Applause]
[Music]
mix it oh okay that was a good hard cut
that was a very good heart
about the 33.
all right that's good enough right there
but at least whoever wanted to see that
the 360 cut or whatever you could that
was a pretty good cut shaking off the uh
the wide receiver
all right so we wanted to see
do some housekeeping before I sign off
so we wanted to see Bengals jerseys we
want to see Team overalls and then maybe
a face scan there's one right there of
uh Jalen Ramsey looks pretty good
uh all right let's look at Team overalls
and the Jersey real quick
since we ended the Vikings game a little
early
so team overalls Chargers 87 Cardinals
84 Tampa 90. I think they're the highest
rated one Cleveland 84 Denver 84. the
bill is 89 it's good Bengals 85.
Chicago 78
Vikings 80 10 c82
Houston 74 Pittsburgh 80 Seattle 76.
New Orleans 82.
Ravens 87 Rams 88 Vader's 83.
Pats 81 why have the mighty have fallen
Panther 79
go pack go 88
Detroit 78
jet 79
damn Jack 77 that's very uh
damn giant 75
Niners 86.
Falcon 77
equals 85 Dolphins 83
the boys 86.
commanders 81 Colts 82
KC 86 and we're back to the charger so
those are the uh
um
those are the the overalls
let's go to the
uh Bengals real quick
show my buddy the uniforms here we go
here's the away
got the color Rush all white
alternate color rush or no that's
current alternate
current color Rush is uh all by it's a
current alternate orange and black
current home option I like this one I
like the current home option a lot I
like the black and orange turn away
black and white 2019's home
2019's away
Andy Dalton
era to match his color Rush
the 1970s was the classics right there
current home yep and there's the there's
the jerseys there you want to look at
some of the helmets got the 1970s
helmets carrying helmet
I think it's just the two you can either
go current Helmet or can go 1970s
there's more helmet options for some of
the other teams but um
but this is the uh
the main one so
there you go and then last order of
housekeeping is looking at some face
scans
check the roster see if it's there
it's got to be right I mean where else
would it be
um
edit rosters
manage players yeah that'd be it right
does it let you see them no it doesn't
how
how do we look up the the face scans
where do you see the the players in in
game
not entirely sure I mean I see him there
I see there's Aaron Donald we saw Jalen
Ramsey earlier
do we have to go in the face of the
franchise because that might be a little
uh that might be tough
or maybe regular franchise mode
press edit player okay
better roster so let's go to uh manage
players
edit player does it show us
oh okay okay I see uh so someone wanted
to see the the DBS Let's uh
let's just go
was there an all option
there we go all NFL
let's take a look
I'm just gonna go through a couple of
them see Jalen Ramsey
right there
let's go to appearance
can I take this helmet off
nah
I don't know how you can just see their
face but hopefully the the face came
with the helmet will uh
we'll suffice for now
maybe if I
oh it just lets me modify it doesn't
actually show his face okay we got
Ramsay there
we got
uh Jared Alexander another great TV
[Music]
someone said to modify the face yeah I
don't know if that works but I mean you
can see you can see the like core
face that they go for him you know here
are some of the face scans they have for
uh customizable characters and then they
just like tweak from there to fit
uh you know whatever player they're
looking for
uh devious White
they look pretty good Denzel Ward
where's sauce
let me see sauce
[Music]
where's he at
[ __ ]
all right I'm gonna I'm gonna give
franchise mode a shot to see but I'm
gonna probably gonna have to wrap this
up and like
two minutes if it's not uh
if it's not there
actually
foreign
great news guys so I got the okay to
play for a little bit longer so we're
actually going to be going until six so
I'm gonna uh start franchise and we can
look at uh their faces with a little
more
um
with more time all right
so everyone say thank you Tay and chat
because he gave the okay for me to hang
out with you guys a little bit longer
uh let's see
uh use real life NFL roster yeah that's
what we want all right yeah let's do
real life NFL roster
uh pick your week I can only pick
preseason let's do that choose the team
you want to start your franchise with
continue ahead
use the options
do I like the game so far yeah that's
all right
you know
it's nice there's nothing crazy about it
but it's it's fun uh uh
uh you know it's pretty fun All Things
Considered
uh all right let's see
um
this place an active player
Nick mullet and let's play as Nick
Mullins y'all I was kidding uh he plays
a receiver
plays as Hunter plays Devonte
99 overall
let's see let's see let's see we got
oh yeah yeah you can see the his face
came for sure look at that
if that's the case I could just I can
just back out and and you know play as
whoever so we can see their face so what
do you guys who do you guys want to see
specifically for the face scans because
we got time now
Chase you're asking what am I playing
I'm playing Madden Madden 23. it's the
Early Access as you can see from the
title of the uh the live stream
yeah those in the chat if you guys want
to see what a uh particular
um
face scan looks like let me know I'm
gonna pop in and out of this uh
franchise so we can see what they look
it means you I can see any face in the
uh
in the view team okay
even better
let's go to NFL rosters huh
see this
is this yeah yeah oh yeah yeah you're
right you're right you're right good
looking chat hell yeah
all right let's we got the whole NFL
roster to go through then let's see what
we uh who we want to see someone said
Brady let's go to Brady
uh
I don't know if if you said that to
troll me but I'll do it for you
uh
uh
let's see
God who's he playing for again
I am just messing with y'all
let's see what old man Brady looks like
yeah
it's got a lot of Botox in him I can see
it
uh TJ watch sure let's do TJ Watt
TJ what were you at my boy
where are the Steelers at
TJ Watts
nice
TJ what
um
Tyree kill
sure
and do Tyreek Hill
where are
the Chiefs at
oh wow
I meant the Dolphins
[Laughter]
there we go see Tyrique Tyrique the
freak
okay
I got his earring
all they're missing is the him holding
up the deuces
um
sorry kill just go to DBS as a whole you
just want to see you you just want to
see every DB in the game don't you
all right let's look at all the let's
look at all the cornerbacks
all right so let's look at Jalen
there's Jalen
and you can tell me you can tell me
swizzy if uh
if it's different than amount of 22
seems like it seems like you've got a
good uh grasp on uh
on all of the uh
uh DBS and their face scans
it's chair Alexander
Davis
uh Denzel Ward
we saw them uh we saw these guys with
their helmets on but the face games
without them they look pretty good
uh
uh Darius Slay
can we see Kayvon after you can see
Devonte can we see Winston Prescott
absolutely I will I will go through uh
each and every one of them I'm kind of
going through the DBS a little bit
for now I kind of want to see what they
look like let's see what Marsha and
Latimore looks like
Stefan Gilmore I'm always curious how
foreign
like how much work goes into trying to
replicate the faces of real life people
on the scale of like an NFL roster it's
a lot of people you know what I mean
okay
they need a completely UI it feels the
same I feel you on that can I tell you
something though you know what I really
appreciate Madden 22 I think my biggest
pet peeve was the amount of uh like
Motion Graphics between
like selecting different game modes so
if you went from franchise to Ultimate
Team to whatever
there was this every step you took every
like button you pressed there would just
be my Xbox would chug trying to load
these graphics and I hated it I hated it
so much
um so far I haven't ran into that issue
with Madden 23 which is nice so all
right uh swizzy if you've got yeah okay
they fired the the DBS nice all right
man I'll take your word for it I'm glad
I'm glad uh
I'm glad they passed that's cool
let me oh my bad let me go back to uh
uh what did I want on view team is that
what it was yeah NFL rushers all right
let me look at what some of you folks
wanted
I aim to please let's see we got uh we
already showed Brady let's look at oh
damn I missed some of the uh
some of the chat
uh okay I see Justin Herbert let me show
I mean
let's do
go back to just the NFL might be faster
this way
and Herbert's probably gonna be up here
yeah there you go this is Justin Herbert
someone wanted Carson Wentz and Dak
Prescott oh nice whoever looks good
they even gave him the like like the
little acne blemishes and stuff
it looks that looks pretty solid
uh okay let's see it's got Rogers Rogers
his goofy ass
Rogers looks a little weird I think it's
the eyes
something about the eyes feel off and
maybe it's the facial hair
yeah I don't know what it is I mean it
looks like Rogers but he also looks a
little weird it's like The Uncanny
Valley effect
um Dak Prescott where's Prescott at
let's look at Dak
yeah okay
not bad
someone wants my home so let's check the
stats the homes overall is 95 84 speed
87 Excel yeah 87 acceleration 88 agility
uh
I don't know what Cod is what uh
what's that that's supposed to be again
but 70 strength 91 awareness 97 throw
power of course 95 short accuracy and 91
middle accuracy medium accuracy 89 deep
accuracy let's see what moms looks like
it's all right his hair doesn't look
that bad actually
usually the problem with hair
for those of you who saw I'm trying to
get a good look at it
um the Madden game that we were playing
like specifically the John Madden Legacy
game so it was the AFC versus the NFC
they showed Madden a few times on the
sideline and his hair looked plastic
this looks kind of good
there's like curls and
nice I
I gotta tip my hat to that one I think
that looks good on my screen it looks
really good
um okay so a few more let me see the
request Carson wins uh oh we didn't show
Carson once yet
Carson Wentz gotta be down here yes sir
on the Commanders
[Music]
yeah
looks about right
73 overall that is brutal man
he fell off he was touted as like the
next big thing for the Eagles his rookie
and sophomore year
but
that didn't pan out uh do you want to
see Devonte Adams yes of course
I showed him earlier but
love Devonte Adams I'm so thrilled we
got him we need a good o-line
on the Raiders to do anything but
it feels great seeing Devante and Derek
together
I want Derek Carr
to be like an MVP so dang bad
that boy cannot
shake off the mid allegations
everyone says Derek Carr's mid he's mid
he's mid he's mid he's not clutch he's
not you know whatever he has like a
really good year in like 2015 I think
then he gets injured and he's never the
same right but I want Derek Carr to
succeed so badly that guy is such a good
human being
like religion aside you know I know not
everyone you know is is likes religion
being you know shoved down their throat
but that guy is a devout Christian and
even though I'm not I love a man he's
such a good person
and I just want to see good things
happen to him
um
she's got that mob of mentality
uh Chief's life in the chat hey Raiders
man she's on you oh no get out of here
bro
uh
uh so I showed you guys Patrick Mahomes
he looked great I thought it was all
photo scans and more refinements for the
top most popular players maybe yeah
maybe if you go to like uh you know
Hassan on Twitch mention that maybe if
you go to like the lowest of the low you
know stat wise maybe they look like crap
who knows Let's uh let's scroll down
real quick to like
the sub 60s maybe see if they if they
stay the same
actually here okay here let's let's look
at Curtis Samuel he's not a top player
but his scan should look
looks okay
um someone wants to see cave on okay
I'll show I'll show you Kayvon
SEC he got me that pick six right I
think earlier
let's go all the way down I'm just gonna
keep going down let's find a a bench
warmer see if they do his uh his face
Justice
Jalen hurts his face model looks
accurate we can pull up Jalen hurts
I'm realizing I should have just started
at the top and just flipped the overall
pancakes
uh Kyler Murray
uh I still gotta show you Kayvon don't
worry
um
Seahawks cornerbacks okay Derek Henry
uh AJ Terrell Travis Kelsey traveler
okay I can go through all of them do not
worry y'all
uh
uh Jason Moore Jr we're gonna pick on
you my friend let's see
if Madden did you did you dirty or did
you justice let's see
nope
nope they did not do you justice my
friend I am sorry
uh
oh God
yeah okay I I didn't know that actually
so Chad you guys showed me so yeah it
seems like they only do face scans for
like the most popular players or the
high ranked ones you know what I mean uh
so let's see let's see if some folks uh
some folks got it okay I oh
kvon that's what I owe okay I gotta find
caveon's a DB right
he's a cornerback
if I'm not mistaken
I literally played this one earlier I
just I can't
[ __ ]
um
Blackhawk let me know what position
Kayvon plays and on what team and I'll
find him for you meanwhile let's look
for Jalen hurts real quick
uh Jalen hurts where you at my boy
there we go Jalen hurts
nice that's a good face scan yeah
linebacker for the Giants Edge rusher
linebacker all right I got you
uh
let's just pull up the Giants might be
easier that way
yeah linebacker
oh there he is
came on
this player's development trait is
hidden put him in your lineup
no that's not a face scan I don't think
I don't think they they got him
nah no it looks a little off right it's
just the facial hair
yeah that's not him there's no way
[Music]
um
see Berta I'm so sorry you've been
saying Seahawks quarterback uh Non-Stop
I got you my boy I got you don't worry
it's the angry phrase that that uh that
got me
Seahawks
where is speed at
speed is that a nickname
is it Sydney Sydney Jones
[Music]
uh
see murder let me know which of uh
the Seahawks DBS or safeties
you want to see let's look at Jamal
Adams
got the face paint
well there's something off about
Andre diggs's body
might be the arms
yeah I feel like it's like the moment
you hit
under 80. or 75
they just give you generic faces
you know what I mean
that's gotta be that's gotta be it
yeah I don't know what what uh speed is
unfortunately uh Cameron dansler
just camera dancer played for in what
position uh
I love all these comments man I'm sorry
I'm getting a little overwhelmed trying
to catch up with everything let's do
Travis Kelsey I see Travis Kelsey
if I haven't got to you I will try to in
the next eight minutes or so before I
sign off
uh
let's grab Kelsey
oh they gave him short hair
and a goatee I feel like he always
changes his hair and facial hair you
know every season or so
Kelsey there
uh Fred Warner finally have a face scan
let's go to the Niners and find out
I might as well grab Kettle actually
while I'm here I want to see what it
looks like
nice okay
give him the man bun and everything
uh okay let's go to the linebackers
let's find Fred Warner
wow
I think that's
not him is it
looks like it could be a generic face
they gave him a
just give him long hair
huh
my homie who uh requested Fred Warner
I'll let you be the judge Fernanda let
me know
if uh
if this is a face kind it looks generic
to me kind of I don't know if it uh if
my eyes playing tricks on me or not
have someone on Twitch mentioned uh uh
Justin Tucker you know kickers are kind
of a low priority but he's so good that
you know maybe they did Justin Tuck
there that's a good point let's let's uh
let's see
if they did Justin Tucker
time duh
looks like they grabbed a generic face
and tried to mold it to look like Justin
Tucker you know what I mean
Nicole Hardman
it's a wide receiver for the Chiefs yeah
got big shoes to fill now with Tyree
Khan
Nicole Hardman
uh rookie cornerback Woolen for the
Seahawks that's who uh speed was do we
crack that case let's see if I can find
them let's see if I can find Woolen
although it sounds like maybe they won't
give him a face scan but I'll uh I'll
check for you
a Woolen Tariq Woolen here we go
foreign
looks like it's a generic
uh let me go Vikings cornerback dancler
nope generic face for Dantzler rip
uh who else we got I showed my cold hard
man do they have Trey lances of FaceCam
yes
um swizzy I know you're asking AJ tarot
let me know position team I'll find AJ
Terrell for you but let me pull up uh
Trey Lance real quick
uh
uh yeah they gave they did a face scan
for trade Lance that's yup yeah that's
for sure Trey
definitely try it
let's look at Jimmy G while we're at it
that's a kind of an odd
Jimmy does not look like that I mean he
does but like again it's like that weird
uncanny valley where it seems like they
kind of like morphed some features you
know
um
uh DB AJ Terrell
to be
for the Falcons okay I got you
falcon
yeah there you go you got a face scan
for sure
for sure it's pretty cool
all right last one let's see Alvin
Kamara
I had Camara on my fantasy team when
um
he scored like six touchdowns on
Christmas
it was quite frankly one of the best
days of my life it was so good
yeah oh they got the deceptic ring and
everything
or septum
I got the septum rain is so sick
so dope man kamark dude Camaro is so
good when he first
uh uh when he first started I remember I
passed him up on fantasy and I was so
upset man but I ended up getting him I
think a year later the year after it was
a couple years later
bro six touchdowns amazing
uh Derek Henry
I recall someone asking Derek Henry
earlier so I gotta do you a favor there
yeah he looks good
they [ __ ] up his hair like three four
years ago but it looks uh
looks pretty solid I can't really turn
them
then he looks good
does the weather change by itself no I
don't think so
I don't think there's any Dynamic
weather and is this EA play correct yes
it is
yes it is hey swissy thanks for the sub
I mean you're not subbing to me you're
subbing the game spot right uh but you
can follow me on Twitter bro if you if
you like the the BS that I like to say
about football all the time I mean it's
all going to be Raider tweets but
um but hey we appreciate you guys
hanging out with us and hopping in the
comments and stuff
it's been a lot of fun
um
I'm just waiting for uh you know as soon
as my my boss uh gets home and gives me
the uh the red light to to turn off the
stream but until here I'm hanging out
with you guys so looks like we got a bit
more uh
maybe a couple more minutes
Jonathan Taylor Justin Jefferson I got
you
Trayvon Dix I think we showed Trayvon
Diggs already
foreign
good running backs are a dime a dozen
man especially those that can stay
healthy
Justin Jefferson
let's take a look at Jefferson and
Phelan
[Music]
yeah nice
dude I'm not gonna lie I think telen I
think thielen
um
would have
blown up if Jefferson went to any other
team the alien was going to be the
Undisputed why were super one he was he
had this insane insane insane year I
recall
and it was him and Stefan Diggs and then
Diggs leaves right Diggs leaves to go to
the bills and it's like oh this is going
to be feelings
uh core of wide receivers and then
Justin Jefferson comes along and just
lights it up right and it's like oh my
God
Daniel Hunter who uh what team and what
uh position I'll pull up Daniel Hunter
and then
we got what do we got Trevor Lawrence
I'll do that also uh Twitter my Twitter
it is at rash b57 so at rash b r o s h
by five seven if you want to follow me I
don't always tweet gaming [ __ ] I tweet a
lot of a lot of [ __ ]
a lot of Raiders stuff a lot of goofy
stuff so you can feel free to mute me
but uh it's always nice to have
folks if they like what I do to follow
I'll try to keep a Game Spot Centric too
uh on occasion
Let's uh let's go to the Jags
Trevor Lawrence
their Subway himself look at that look
at that hair
that hair
looks simultaneously
disgusting and great at the same time I
don't know what I don't know what it is
Holy shoo yeah look at that
there's something about the part of the
hair that's like throwing me off
uh Vikings uh DN all right I got you uh
Daniel Hunter let's do it oh my bad my
bad my bad
I'll go back to Trayvon Diggs we did see
him earlier but I'll go back to Trayvon
Dix and then I'll I'll get a Daniel
Hunter
's Trayvon Dukes
[Music]
uh can I look at the Bears yes I can
after I do the Vikings real quick
Amir Abdullah on the Raiders right I'll
pull up Amir Abdullah I don't know if
they have a face game for him but
um sorry let me gather my thoughts who
was I looking at first okay so Daniel
Hunter first and then looking at the
Bears and then Amir Abdullah
uh Vikings
Vikings
oh I pass him yes I did
uh
right and
CT
Daniel Hunter
why is he not on here oh there he is my
bad
there's Danielle Hunter
I'll go I'll go to Josh Allen in a sec
uh Daniel Chad you got mad at 23 all
Madden Edition on Xbox we can't play
right now but you installed the app
before it was out you know um there
people have been having mixed bags with
being able to to pop in uh into the game
so
uh yeah it looks like Daniel had a
generic face sadly
who am I looking at drive on I already
showed Trayvon Diggs let's look at the
Bears Amir Abdullah and Josh Allen okay
go back to the rosters
bills
see if they get Josh Allen is a little
mole that he's got on his face
yeah nice
looks good it looks like it just got out
of bed but looks good
uh Daniel should you uninstall it and
install it yeah yeah I don't think you
have anything to lose if it's not
working and you have EA play and you
want the Early Access I would uh
uninstall the game and reinstall
but that's just me
um
bearsdbs
swizzy just loves the DVS man I swear
let's go to the Raiders find a mirror
Abdullah real quick
yeah yeah not a not a generic face
that's a that's
a good face can
they probably did from his time with the
with the lines you know what I mean and
they just had it
um
okay so did Josh Allen did Amir Abdullah
did Trayvon Diggs uh I need to look at
the Bears
Khalil Mack
Andrew Perkins
serger
allele
contactors
yeah nice
God man we should have kept him
Chandler Jones Khalil Mack on the d-line
right now Devonte Adams on offense
Hunter Renfro
Derek Carr Josh Jacobs
could have been
uh okay I gotta look up Vikings
linebackers got Kendrick Perkins
or Eric Kendricks rather
Kendrick Perkins a basketball player
whoa
yeah
how about those Chiefs how about them
patriots no none of them I'm going to
the Bears
because I promised homeboy the Bears
uh
uh roster
maybe Madden hates the uh the bike the
Vikings bro
roquan Smith
see David Montgomery I never know if I
should draft David Montgomery I feel
like some years it's like a no-go and
then some years he's like really good
you know let's get Eddie Jackson
Mooney
Darnell Mooney the reason why Alshon
Jeffrey couldn't catch a ball
let's look at Justin Fields where's he
at
they for sure had a face scan him if
they did a generic yeah yeah
look at some Eagle players and look at
the rookies
I don't know who the eagle brookies are
I think we I think we saw um Jalen hurts
though we pulled him up from the Eagles
quarter will Patterson
quarter bells on the Falcons now right I
don't think he's with the Raiders
anymore
yeah there we go
[Music]
that ain't him
is it
I feel like corduro has uh larger eyes
it could be that it was a maybe an older
face skin and they just like try to
touch it up you know
so
uh look some Eagle players Bobby Wagner
Wagner's still with the Hawks right
foreign
ER not
a Seahawk
am I tripping
Bobby Wagner
always with the Rams
damn okay
let's grab the ramps
there he is
kinda
uh new kid how does it look so far this
is the first Madden I purchased that
release in three years
that might be the way to do it dude you
know what I mean like if you're a Madden
fan you just stick with one and then
after like three years so like yeah
that's now's a good time to make the
jump you know what I mean that might be
the way because it's probably gonna feel
a lot better Madden 23 versus Madden 20
is probably a big jump compared to
Madden 23 versus Madden 22. you know
what I mean uh we saw sauce earlier I'll
I'll bring them up again
why not
times
we got sauce right here I think they
gave him a generic face but I don't
remember
that kind of
something about the mustache is throwing
me off
uh
Frank Clark
nope they gave him cornrows yo I'll take
Frank Clark
uh Joey Bosa
see if they got the nose right oh yeah
that's Bosa
uh I suppose for sure
same darnold he's on Panthers
kind of wanted darnold to be good I
always want rookie quarterbacks to be uh
let's see McCaffrey always won rookie
quarterbacks to do well man that's a
tough position to play
let's look at Baker I forgot Baker's on
that Beard yo
uh wide
receiver oh what am I looking at viruses
freaking QB uh let's look at Sam's
Arnold
yeah that's a face scan
the kind of like
brought the eyebrows down a little bit
made them look like this but it seems
that
uh let me pull up sick one
real quick
uh please play a game probably can't man
sorry I uh
I uh uh we played a bunch earlier I'm
kind of going through these right now
well actually no I can't if you guys are
good with with looking at these faces
I'll pull up uh Judy and then maybe
we'll uh we'll end it at that and I'll
and I'll hop into a game real quick but
the stream will be ending soon I was
supposed to close it at six I'm just
waiting for uh my boss to get back
to his home to the the workstation so we
could end it from there but so we're
really
kind of operating on borrowed time
um
so who's I looking again Jerry Judy
that's right
this front is Bronco
Jerry and Judy
yeah
nice
all right let's get out of franchise
okay
I still couldn't find a way to do a
fantasy draft and Ultimate Team yet but
I was uh
last one drink okay I will go back for
Jake London because I actually do kind
of want to see if they did anything for
him because he's supposed to be
you know he's kind of all you guys have
for the Falcons right on the receiving
Court
um versus instead of um
you guys do have Kyle Pitts though and
Kyle Pitts should
boom hopefully
I was a Kyle Pitts believer last year
uh let's look at Drake London
South it's where you at
and hit boys got some beats oh you have
Calvin yeah but Ridley like took the
year off is he back this year
uh Drake London
foreign
the lighting was a little weird there
for a second but
yeah
we got Drake London
overly suspended for betting on games
that's right
but didn't he also like take the year
off
last year like for his health like he
was like Hey I'm I'm not playing like
it's I'm stressed or like I'm having
issues or whatever like
you don't think that's close Jake London
let me see
oh yeah no I think you're right
that makes sense
I mean to be honest it seems like they
put in some effort in tweaking like it's
not a face scan but they put some effort
into like tweaking and molding the
custom face to fit his whereas we've had
um
whereas we we've had like other players
like I think like Fred Warner uh someone
mentioned was like yo he's like the
biggest uh you know linebacker one of
the best at his position and he just
didn't have a face scan and they didn't
even try it was like a totally
completely off the Mark
um
you know type scan
I'll get you to uh and then I'm gonna
hop into a game so we can get some
action going before uh until I'm told
that I I gotta turn it off
there's Tua
it looks pretty good for him
I don't know why it's so dark though
every time I click on the player it's
like on my screen it's like really dark
and then I'll like slowly fades in I
can't tell if that's a bug or not
so what's the reason why I'm a Raiders
fan exotic gaming on YouTube asks uh
it's a fun question it's a good question
so you know born and raised in the Bay
Area you are either a Niner fan a Raider
fan or both if you are just you know you
just support the bay or whatever it is
um we have people here who live in
Pittsburgh in the Bay Area and they'll
be Steelers fans because it's Pittsburgh
even though it's not there Pittsburgh so
it's just like whatever right unless if
you were born into a family
that was like yo we are Niners fans we
are Raider fans you know what I mean
it's you were kind of like wishy-washy
or if you're a kid you kind of bandwagon
right I mean both the Niners the Niners
were thriving in the 90s uh the Raiders
were okay and in 2002 I think they even
made it to the Super Bowl with uh Jon
Gruden so they were doing their thing
around that time I was just a kid I was
like maybe six seven years old on the
playground
and um my family I mean they're you know
an Afghan immigrant uh family I'm the
first person born in the States you know
for my family so they don't know what
the [ __ ] football even was right they
played soccer
um
so for me to be honest dude it was just
like being on the playgrounds and and
seeing uh the jerseys right seeing
seeing what what other people
um wore and you would have Woodson
jerseys for the Raiders you would have
Steve Young jerseys for the Niners you
would have Trail uh Terrell Owens Tim
Brown there's a lot of raider jerseys a
lot of Niner jerseys and they were both
really really cool so it could have gone
either way and at the time when I
decided to like kind of look at football
um I was like yo
you just gotta pick right you just pick
and you commit and at the time uh
Raiders were doing really well and so I
bandwagon on the Raiders but I committed
with all you know shouts out to me I'm
gonna Pat myself on the back that I
committed to the Raiders because right
after we lost that Super Bowl it was
just downhill we were just a poverty
franchise so you know
uh it is what it is
all right y'all this will be the last
game most likely I'm going to
um play this through until I get a
message from my boss basically saying
he's ready to turn the stream off so I
might end it in the middle of the game
might end it at the end but let's have a
good
uh let's have a good time
how different is face of the franchise
um I I can actually answer that face of
the franchise is different in the sense
that I don't think that there is a lot
of
um
there's no like story mode of like you
coming up uh as a high schooler or as a
prospect there's like all these weird
drama or none of that none of that crap
from the old Madden games the face of
the franchise now when you start facing
the franchise you're starting with your
player
um already having played in the NFL for
five years so it's like they're a
veteran you're taking control of a
veteran
um
so hey Gotham on Twitch thanks for
stopping by appreciate it man uh and uh
enjoy the rest of your day man thanks
Rising gaming system I like the Chiefs
come on of course not of course not I
don't like the cheese I mean I don't
hate any one team besides maybe the
Patriots
um but I'm not friendly towards Chargers
or Broncos or chiefs you know teams
right but like I'm also not like uh oh
I'm gonna start a fight like a Dodgers
Fanwood you know so sometimes
performance solely by judging them any
chance I can run a CPU for CPU games
probably not I'd rather just play you
know what I mean
it would be nice I mean I'm playing
against the CPU
a time for Mac Jones in his Patriot
offense to take defense thanks for your
questions is Madden any good and you
hope this mountain is better than last
year
um
Madden is Madden if you like Madden
you'll like this if you don't like
Madden you won't like this that's the
way that I look at it
um
you know the three hours I think that
we've been streaming now it's been I've
enjoyed my time
and the few kind of like new mechanics
whether if they're a little gimmicky or
if they're actually game changing have
been feeling pretty uh pretty
interesting
pass there of the bear that's almost a
rhythm Point that's what we like to call
it get them into Rhythm early something
safe something they're confident about
something they feel good but once it's
completed then you just keep moving from
there would have sent Matt Jones
City Missouri same place as tech nine
that's why you're a Chiefs fan because
you're the chiefs of St Louis yeah man
that's that's how it works you know if
you it's either like you have a family
like you come from a family of like
Giants fans even if you're across the
country you're a Giants fan right
um or it's it's where you grow up right
in the game it's it's hard to go against
the grain of your hometown
is part of your identity you know what I
mean
in college I remember playing as uh you
know playing with Kobe in 2K and I was
like yo I'm a Lakers fan like this is
sick I love Kobe you know and he retired
and I was like oh he's the greatest and
someone looked at me was like dude he's
from the bay like how are you not a
Warriors fan and I was like oh [ __ ]
right you know what I mean so it's just
like the importance of repping your
hometown or at least respecting your
hometown scenes is really big dick
Jones he gets it into the arms of Parker
complete uh series X uh yes this is a
series X that's what I'm playing right
now
[Music]
Ben oh yeah originally from the bay area
do you live in Missouri now there you go
yeah
one of their priorities
[Applause]
to get it done
good number of coverages at him make him
think as he's running downfield and
hopefully you can create a little bit
had a punter Bailey on now as he sends
this one away
[Applause]
and that one hits at the seven but
bounds into the end zone
all right that is the Raiders take over
on offense we get to see the man who has
been the leader of this team for nine
Seasons now to pre-order Madden 2K
bro at the 20. off the play fake he'll
look to throw well he's going to take a
shot right away
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh no this isn't the right formation
[Applause]
first rep of the game for Josh Jacobs
and he'll get only a couple up to the
22. I mean in search of eight yards here
as they hope to convert the first down
do I like Brady of course not no I don't
on third down here I mean I don't I
don't like hate the guy I don't like
eight anyone but I have a lot of disdain
for Brady
you know of course at the defensive
tactical position yes he's busy um but
still bloody agile is he but I
it's like it's very rare
for me to find an athlete that I'm like
I
hate this person like everything they're
about do you know what I mean it's like
it doesn't make sense uh to me because
they're all they're all people and
they're all just doing jobs Brady is a
Bay Area kid you know Brady's the Cali
you know what I mean like it's using
just a little bit of the edge after back
to back punts it's kind of hard to uh
do I want him to lose of course
absolutely
home same thing as as Brady you know
what I mean the thing is is that
especially when with the amount of
fantasy football that I play
um the the idea of of game respects game
pops into my head
so it's like
you gotta you just gotta respect the
talent you know what I mean so it's
Brady I got a respect the talent I it
doesn't matter if you see the meme when
he's got the rings on his hand and each
one has a uh a little text that says
like deflate gay you know spy gate all
that stuff like that's all fine
okay that's all fine but at the end of
the day when you win six Super Bowls
like it's like all right good yardage
you know what I mean look yeah I get it
you're gonna be the greatest full-time
am I happy about it of course not but
this defense is never gonna be like
you're not a bad player you're not
overrated same thing with uh sitting
with my homes
here early on if you've played for any
team besides the Chiefs I'd probably be
blotting in fact the way that I talk in
the game today the way that I talk for
um the way that I talk about Josh Allen
is probably how I would talk about uh
you know but like I said man I don't I
don't hate the guys you know they're
they're really really great athletes
there was one play that in the homes did
where he was scrambling and he looked
back at the rest
ahead he looked back at the ref and it
was the scene it was to see if he uh had
gotten like the okay like if the the
flag like where the flag ref had thrown
a flag looked back to basically see if
it was taking place and that was the
most incredible like here's a guy that's
playing this game in slow motion he's
that good you know what I mean
um
who's my favorite quarterback Josh Allen
right now Josh Allen uh from a like
I just loved because he was an underdog
when he got drafted everyone said he was
overrated the bills made a mistake
um I also am a fan of redemption stories
I know that
um Josh Allen made some mistakes
in college and not to get into like uh
type thing but I know that when you're a
young person like that and you worked so
hard to get to the NFL uh it's a
childhood dream boy and here's someone
who's basically being ripped or a
mistake that they made and I I really
wanted to see him this is not a thriving
as like a Redemption story you know what
I'm saying so I think I that's why I
love Joshua I think he's looking for
this awesome he's got all this talent
and he looks like he's genuinely
remorseful and he turned a new leap so
you know
other than otherwise Derek Carr
absolutely
accepted
oh
so but these are great great questions
guys here's what I'm gonna do I'm going
to throw
absolutely situation to Devonte whether
if he is in triple coverage or not uh
and that'll be the last play of this
stream all right
[Applause]
you got to give me a better um
[Music]
with a big difference last year Josh
McDaniels was the offensive coordinator
of the Pats this year he's the head man
in Las Vegas so this a game of course
[Applause]
doesn't score
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh man what do I think about the game
between Josh Allen Petro homes amazing I
love that game so much that was so
incredible but hey guys um I'm that's
gonna wrap it up for me actually so if I
just got home I'm about to turn this
stream off I want to thank each and
every one of you guys for uh for joining
us this was a lot of fun usually Madden
streams can be really toxic but you guys
were a great group uh he had a lot of
great questions
it was just fun we had we had a blast
you know all the
chaos of the Madden games and the pick
sixes and you know the the earlier
Raider game it was a lot of fun so once
again I am David amadi I'm a video
producer for Gamespot you can follow me
on Twitter at rosh b r o s h e y five
seven
um we're gonna have a video review
coming up soon so you can throw some
more comments in there and thanks again
man so that's gonna do it for me all
right
enjoy the rest of your week
God bless
Phillips he's not going to bring this
one out so they will begin the drive at
the 25. the Vegas offense ready for
their next possession not only are they
in search of their first score they're
in search of their first first down in
this ball game as they come up First and
Ten